>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Well, I've said this 21 times
before so, ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the 22nd annual
Vardanants Day Lecture Series,
Armenian Lecture Series.
This year -- well,
they're all been special
but this year is really special
because we have a conference
with some of my friends,
colleagues and academic types
to fill your day talking about
Armenian history and culture.
But before I began, and
before we start this program,
I'd like to introduce you
to a colleague of many years
who has held many, various
positions at the Library
of Congress, of importance
to the collections
and the preservation of those
collections, and I'm delighted
to introduce him thanks to the
appointment by the new librarian
of Congress Dr. Carla Hayden,
I'd like to introduce you
to Mr. Mark Sweeney, who is now
the principal deputy librarian
of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank You, Lee.
Ladies and gentlemen, welcome
to the Library of Congress
in today's 22nd Vardanants
Day, Armenian Lecture Series.
I'm delighted to be
addressing you in this hall
in the historic Thomas Jefferson
Building, attached to a room
on there that is dedicated to
Woodrow Wilson, the president
of so many important
moments in history,
especially of the Armenians
in the early part
of the 20th century.
In 1991m Mrs. Marjorie Dadian
made a generous donation
to the Near East Section in
the name of our husband Arthur,
for the health and maintenance
of the Armenian collections.
That gift not only allowed us
to appoint the first
Armenian area specialists,
but also was the
genesis of a long-running
and very successful olestra
series, which began in 1994,
which is why we're here today.
Since that time, the Armenian
collections have grown
from some 7,000 items
to over 40,000 --
45,000 items in our collection.
The Near East section has
sponsored conferences,
such as the American response to
the Armenian Genocide in 2000,
a major exhibit in 2012 to
celebrate the 500th anniversary
of the first printed
Armenian book.
That exhibit to note wisdom
and instruction the
Armenian literary tradition
at the Library of Congress,
brought nearly a quarter
of a million visitors here to
the library into the galleries.
The Library of Congress
remains an described important
repository of the
world's heritage,
this universal collection.
And we're proud to include
among those ancient,
yet still vibrant cultures, the
history of the Armenian people,
as exemplified in the talks
of the scholars you will
soon hear today and enjoy.
Again, welcome to the
Library of Congress
and please enjoy
today's program.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Mark Sweeney.
None of these programs
have happened in a vacuum.
We have many people who are
responsible for supporting,
for helping erect everything
that in the construction
of lectures and exhibits, some
of whom I will mention later.
But at this point the most
important is the next speaker,
Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb who is
the chief of the African
and Middle Eastern Division who
has been a constant supporter
of all my Armenian programs,
and this one in particular
since it is a special edition
of the Vardanants series.
So, please, join me in
welcoming Dr. Mary Jane Deeb.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank You, LaVon, and
thank you Mark Sweeney,
for all your support and
for everything you've done.
So, honored guests, ladies
and gentlemen good morning.
I too wish to welcome you
to the Library of Congress.
And in the name of the Division,
the African Middle
East division,
which is hosting
this program today.
I would like to use
the little time I have
to recognize all those who have
made possible this program.
It takes a village,
as the saying goes,
to put together a
program such as this one,
that brings together the
best and brightest colors
in Armenian history
under one roof, or,
in the case of the
Thomas Jefferson Building,
under one dome.
My thanks go first and
foremost to Dr. Lebon Abdulyang,
the organizer of this and the
21 other Vardanants programs
that have put the Armenian
collections at the Library
of Congress, at the very heart
of any scholarly
research work on Armenia.
The French have a wonderful
term "uncontournable",
that loosely translates to
"unmissable", or "inescapable",
and most aptly describes
the status
of our Armenian collections
today.
This is thanks to
LaVon's efforts
in developing these collections,
as well as with outreach efforts
to make these collections better
known in the United States
and throughout the world.
Thanks go to Mark Sweeney,
who not only has taken time
from his extremely busy
schedule to be with us today
for Vardanants day, but who
has, throughout his tenure
as associate librarian, acting
deputy librarian and now
as a primary deputy librarian,
been extremely supportive
of the African and
Middle Eastern division,
giving us funding for new staff,
for microfilming
our newspapers --
including the Armenian
newspapers,
and giving us badly needed space
to shell our ever-growing
collections.
My thanks also go to
Helena Syncome, the director
of collections and
services and her staff,
for their support regarding
all the administrative aspects
involved in planning an
event such as this one.
Thanks to the Communications
Office that worked
on announcing the program and
sending out press releases,
the special events office
that turned this room
into the wonderful conference
hall that you're enjoying,
and arranging with the
caterer for breakfast,
for lunch, for breaks.
To John Regan, who via his sound
system ensures, as he has today
and has for the past 20 years,
ensured that we can all
hear what is being said,
despite the echoes in the room,
that we can all see
what we are showing
on our PowerPoint presentations
and on whom we have
depended on all those years.
I want to thank the webcasting
team that's behind you
that has been filming our
programs and all our events.
And that is of critical
importance
because you'll be able to go
back to your students and say,
"I was there, I gave
this lecture,
I had colleagues whom I had not
met before, they're all there --
all the top scholars are
there", and share this
with your students, because
this is part of the archives
of this division, our webcast.
I want to thank you, last
but certainly not least.
Thank you all for
coming and being with us,
to celebrate this very special
day in Armenian history.
I know you will very much
enjoy the program today.
The speakers have traveled
from far and wide just to be
with you, and to have
and to share the research
and their work here at
the Library of Congress.
So, thank you all for
being here, thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> My thunder has
just been taken away
because Mary Jane has thanked so
many of the people that I wanted
to thank heart full
-- with my heart full.
It happens that you deal with
so many people here and this is,
if anything, an extremely
collegial institution.
But I'd be remiss if I did
not point out a few others.
Dr. Paul Crego has been
my partner in acquisitions
and cataloguing of both
Armenian and Georgian,
and he also dabbles in
Amharic and other languages.
Tomorrow Ohanyan and Clare Dego
of the conservation department
have taken truly unusable
manuscripts and valuable
Armenian items and turned them
into bibliographic gold.
John Evans, the former
ambassador to Armenia who is
in attendance as he usually is,
has been a great
supporter of our programs.
"The voice of America",
with Armen hiding his face
behind a camera has been a
constant source of
publicity for our programs.
I want to thank them and I
want to thank the speakers
that you will hear today.
Each and every one of
them I count a friend
and a dear colleague.
Now, I purposely did not
write down my introduction
to Armenian history because I
didn't know how much time I had,
but since I had this time,
I'll speak for about an hour is
that -- no [laughter].
No? OK, fine.
Let me tell you the
genesis of this conference.
A little over a year ago I
was approached by someone
from the Smithsonian
and said, "this festival
on Armenian culture is
happening, would the library
like to do something to
complement this festival?"
And I said, "absolutely".
And I said, "now,
what could I do?"
Now, I had been wanting to
invite Dr. Armen Matterosian
and Dr. Luke Vartan Baronian to
participate in the conference
because of their work on
R2 and genetics etcetera,
and I built this
conference around them.
And I must tell, you I invited
these dear people and not one
of them took more than
24 hours to say, "yes,
we would like to participate".
However, Dr. Baronian
is not here
because of an unavoidable
emergency
and Armen has told me he
did not plan it this way,
but his wife was due
yesterday so, I said,
"you're forgiven
for not attending".
This year marks the 50th
anniversary of my beginning
to study Armenian history
and culture, academically.
I take this study so seriously
that I will no longer call it
"Armenian Studies",
because that reduces it
to almost a ghetto studying of
Armenian history and culture.
This is the scholarly study
of Armenia, including history,
linguistics, literature.
One of the things that is
maddening that I find --
with every culture, but
Armenian in particular,
is the fact that there
are certain tropes
that everyone knows.
You know, the ark
landed on Mount Ararat,
Armenia as first Christian
country, the genocide,
the kingdom of Silesia.
People know this, but
what they don't know is
from the very first
solid mention of Armenia
in the 6th century BC by the
Greek geographer Heckatias
of Mialitus and on a
Persian inscription
of Darrius the Great,
from that time
to the present there
is an exceedingly rich
and largely unknown history.
So, I said -- I wrote to
my dear friends and said,
"I would like anything but first
Christian country, genocide
and the ark landing
on Mount Ararat".
If everyone had been able
to come you literally would
have gone away at 5 o'clock,
totally confused because you
would have been bombarded
with fact after fact and
richness after richness.
You still are going to
go away not confused,
but very enlightened about
this very rich history.
I'm just going to say two things
that you need to both know
about Armenia before
we continue.
Look at the map.
You will see that Armenia
historically has been
in eastern Anatolia,
the Armenian plateau
and up to the Caucasus.
East-west transit,
very easy, north-south,
transit extremely difficult.
So, and this is known
as Garzonian's law
after Nina Garzon at
Columbia University.
When the surrounding powers --
because Armenia was
always a client state
between surrounding powers,
were equal in strength or equal
in weakness, Armenia flourished
because east-west trade
transit was plentiful.
When, however, one of those
entities grew stronger,
it created a vacuum, sucking the
other power into guess where?
Armenia, and it was
at these periods
that Armenia did not thrive.
That is a constant in Armenian
history, most of the time it was
to surrounding powers -- I
could argue now but I won't,
that we have five at the moment.
So, and the other constant is
the fact that Armenia thrived
and survived because there
were communities on top
of many different
mountains, and when one fell,
the other one existed.
This fostered independence
but it also fostered a feeling
against a centralized authority.
Those are the two constants
of Armenian history,
and within those constants,
I want you to listen
to everything that follows.
And what is going to
follow right now is
from my dear friend Helen C.
Evans the Metropolitan Museum
of Art.
She is the Mary and
Michael Jahara's curator
for Byzantine Art.
I am not going to give
you an entire biography
because that's why I
prepared this program.
While she is talking,
you may read it.
The one thing I want
to draw your attention
to about Dr. Evans is that she
is curating yet another exhibit,
and this exhibit is on Armenia,
a huge exhibit on Armenian Art,
which will open at the
Metropolitan Museum
of Art on September 22nd.
So, at this point, Dr. Helen
Evans, to speak on Silesia
on Mongol trade routes.
[ Applause ]
>> So, as the first speaker,
I would like to be the first
to thank LaVon, not just
for organizing today
but for all he's done farming
in studies in the United States,
by what he's done at the Library
of Congress over so many years.
Its effect is something that we
don't always fully think about,
but we really should
always admire.
So, I hope very much
that all of you join me
in admiring him and
what he's done.
As I hope you will know from
him, we will open an exhibition
on medieval Armenian art
at the MET this fall,
on September 22nd.
And in our research for the
exhibition and its catalog,
I and other catalog authors
have realized that our view
of the role of the Mongols,
in terms of Silesia,
as well as greater Armenia,
should be reconsidered.
The devastation caused by
the Mongols as they advanced
into greater Armenia in the
early 1200s has been described
by Gregoria Wagner in Caracas
[inaudible] and recorded
in numerous manuscript
color fonts.
However, the exhibition's
research has shown
that there was another,
more positive aspect
of the interaction between
the Mongols and the Armenians
in Silesia and greater Armenia
that should be studied further.
That aspect is how much the
critical role Armenians played
on the trade routes of the packs
Mongolica [phonetic] contributed
to Armenian wealth in Silesia
and greater Armenia during the
second half of the 13th century
and well into the 14th century.
This talk introduces the topic
from an art historical
perspective,
in the hope that others will
study the matter further.
As someone whose primary
research has been on the kingdom
of Silesia, I'm approaching the
issue through evidence there.
Like others, I've
always recognized
that the Silesian king had the
first alliance with the Mongols
in the early 1250's
was important.
However, when viewing the
handsome, fortified ruins
of the Armenian killing
Kingdom of Silesia
on the Mediterranean coast,
I've never adequately considered
the source of the funds required
to maintain such magnificent
sites as the hegemon fortress
of Lambrom on the
right and the walls
of the Silesian capital
of Cyss on the left.
I hope to show today
that from the time this
of the Silesian-Mongol
Alliance until the fall
of the Silesian Kingdom
in the late 14th century,
Silesian control of
Mongol trade routes was key
to the great Kingdom's
wealth and authority.
Richly gilded royal
portraits like these
of king Heptune's son LaVon
and his wife display
elaborate silk robes.
What was the source of the
silks in 1262 when LaVon
and lady Quran were shown if
their marriage on the left,
and a decade later when
they knelt in prayer
with their children
on the right?
It's not enough to argue as
I long have that these images
with their extensive
references to Byzantine art,
were only evidence of
the increasing power
of the Silesian state
and its ambition
to be the new Byzantium, as the
power of the Empire weakened
with the Fourth Crusade in 1204.
It is relevant that they
displayed their ambition
by increasingly adopting
the Royal images and dress
of the Byzantine emperors.
At their wedding, the young
royals are shown being blessed
by Christ, as found
in Byzantine art,
and Prince LaVon wears the
tablon of Byzantine Royals
on his tunic -- on his mantle.
A few years later, when they
kneel beneath the Byzantine
douses, now king LaVon and
queen Quran, they are dressed
like the Byzantine emperors,
including wearing
the imperial laurels.
Nothing in the images
directly relates to Mongols.
Rather the only other
external influence is the West,
as shown in the kneeling poses
and the crowns of the royals
and the Queen Quran
Gospel on the right.
What is relevant today
is to consider the source
of the wealth that supported
the richly gilded portraits
and the ambitions
of the Silesian ruling
class they portray.
I am arguing that the
answer was a control
of trade routes for the Mongols.
Armenians had long
been of critical force
on the Silk Route
trade, east-west,
as LaVon referred to
with the Garzoian.
In the 13th century with
arrival the Mongols,
the Armenians ultimately were
able to maintain a similar role
under Mongol rule, and
expanded, by controlling Ayahs,
as we will see, a major
port city for the exchange
of goods with the West.
The expanse of the textile trade
for Silesia is most
easily visible
in these two manuscripts written
for archbishop Johannes John,
the brother of King Heptune The
First and uncle of King LaVon.
On the left, in the
Marshall Ocean gospel of 1274
from the Morgan Library,
the archbishop wears a
fleur-de-lis decorated vestment
and he's to the far left.
That is representative
of Western Europe,
most especially France.
He presents the marshal's family
to the Virgin they are kneeling,
and she is reaching --
extending her mantle over them.
That's opposed, most closely
associated with Minnuchio's
"Madonna of the Franciscans",
as their necessity
unrecognized long ago.
On the right in 1289,
the year of his death,
the Archbishop's tunic is
decorated with a Chinese dragon.
Dikron Kim Jong has linked
the Dragons posed to a textile
in the MET's collection,
from East Central Asia,
a region under Mongol control.
You see a fleur-de-lis
textile beside the early image
of the archbishop on the left,
and the MET's Chinese dragon
beside his later image
on the right.
The fabrics of the Arts bishops
two vestments represent the
extreme ends of Silesia
trade routes.
To the west, links to France,
whose King Louis the Ninth had
allied so closely with Silesia
when he came East on
crusade, that on his return
to France he left his
ward Bowman the Sixth,
the young Prince of Antioch
under the care of King Heptune.
To the east, a continued
Armenian presence
on the silk routes that were
now under Mongol control.
By the dates of bishop
John's manuscripts,
the Silesian state had extensive
links with the Mongols.
To avoid Mongol military
conquests that had happened
in greater Armenia, King Heptune
had surrendered the harem
of the Seljuk ruler,
who had been sent to him
for safety to the Mongols.
Constable Simbad had
to his older brother,
then went to the Mongol
capital at Karakorum in Siberia
and 1247-48, where he
successfully arranged the first
treaty between the Mongols
and a Christian state
which had not been invaded.
When Simbad returned to Silesia,
he brought with him
a Mongol wife,
as Mongol treaties were
confirmed by marriage alliances.
The son of that alliance is
recorded as being present
at the Silesian court
in 1264-65,
evidence of the Silesian
state's role as a vassal
of the Mongols was also clear
clearly demonstrated in 1260,
when King Heptune, accompanied
by the Prince of Antioch,
marched with the Mongols as
they entered Damascus upon their
conquest of the city.
Silesia's port cities,
especially Ayahs,
are an understudied link in
the appreciation of the wealth
that came to Silesia through
control of Mongol trade routes.
The Western book of
Marbles illuminated in 1271,
shows Ayahs as a busy
city, filled with men
and Western dress as
you see on the left.
But it was a Silesian
city, and by that fact,
the westernmost port
of the Mongol Empire.
Western Europeans who wish
to reach the east for trade,
or as missionaries,
were most likely
to enter the east through Ayahs.
Most famous of those was
Marco Polo, who went east
through the port in 1271.
He recorded that it was a city
full of spices and textiles
of wool and cloth of gold, that
were brought there from inland,
clearly meaning that these
goods were then transported
further west.
The image on the screen
doesn't record in a way
that we can recognize the
Silesians who rule the city,
are any Mongols who would
have been interested
in protecting their
Western north city,
yet they were present.
And this is shown on a portalon,
a chart of the Mediterranean
Sea routes of 1339 on the right.
Let's see if I can
make this work.
Silesia -- boy, that's
doing no good.
So, come two-thirds of the
way down and third of the way
over you see kind
of a green square,
that is Silesia and
it's port cities.
The Silesian flags in this
western map are prominently
displayed and Eius and the
other solution ports of Tarsus
and Cortez are clearly
identified
within the green area, if
you can see it clearly.
What's also interesting is
that the two mount peaks
of Mount Ararat are, if you go
up, and there's a red square
and then right to the side
of that are two green Peaks,
which actually have
Noah's Arc on them,
and are clearly identified
as Mount Ararat.
And I think -- I would suggest
that that shows that they know
that goods are traveling through
greater Armenia to reach Silesia
to be loaded onto the ships
whose roots are being shown
on this map.
And that this is
a relevant aspect
of what makes Silesia
so wealthy.
Mongol Authority and Silesia in
the early 1300s is most visible
and the illumination of
king LaVon the fourth
by Sergei's pit sack of 1331.
The text is a translation
of a crusader legal code,
the ascesis of Antioch meant for
use in Silesia, and King LaVon
on the upper right wears
a western fleur-de-lis
inspired crown.
However, he sits cross-legged on
a low throne, the type of pose
and throne found in depictions
of Mongol authorities.
By this date, the Western
presence through intermarriage
and connections with the
Catholic Franciscans was
so widespread in Silesia that it
would seem logical for the King
to be shown sitting,
as in the West.
And I would argue
that his Eastern pose
in this image should be
understood as further evidence
of the important of
Silesia relations
with their Mongol overlords,
whom we know had troops
in Silesia that often
functioned his tax collectors.
Silesian's links with the
Mongols have been have --
excuse me, Silesian links
with the Mongols must
have included connections
with the trade routes
the Armenians
of Greater Armenia controlled
for the Mongols also.
Rachel Kashkarian and the
exhibition catalogue notes
that the authority
of Silesia was such,
that around 1200 Anni
refused to make changes
in religious practices without
the approval of the King
of Silesia and the
patriarch of Romkla.
Evidence of continuing
connections
between Greater Armenia arsal
and Silesia are also
found in manuscripts.
A colophon and a
commentary on Isaiah records
that it was written
in Silesia in 1295 --
1299 before being sent to
the monastery of Gladsor,
whose school was called
a "Second Athens".
The portrait of S.A
Negetski on the right,
he's at the upper left
who was its great teacher,
was added to the
work at Gladsor.
Wealthy Armenian families,
especially the Prussians
and Arabellians funded
the school.
This is the era when
the Persians, Karyans
and Orbellians flourished
through their control
of trade routes for the Mongols.
Through greater Armenia
and perhaps beyond,
our historical evidence of
the wealth of the Persians
and the exhibition includes
this handsome reliquary
of the true cross on the left
that Prince Asayah dedicated
to a monastery of vegetarians,
providing perpetual problems
with what to call it, his
portrait is at the base.
You see it in detail that I
blew up, with his hands raised
in prayer in the
ancient Christian manner.
His son, Emir Hassan,
completed the monastery
"The White Virgin" begun by his
father that is at the top right,
and decorated it with an
image of himself hunting
in Mongol dress, that
you see below it.
I would suggest that the
Mongol features on both
of these men may
indicate that the family,
like Constable Simbad in Silesia
seam it at their authority
with the Mongols by the
necessary intermarriage
with the elite, because
it was the way
on treaties were concluded.
And to conclude, I
am going to be brief.
I believe that further study
is needed of the relations
between the Mongols
and Armenians
of Silesia and greater Armenia.
This nativity scene of 1311
has long been considered
to be a work created in
the Mongol capital Tabriz.
Silvie Marion, who is speaking
today, as shown in the catalogue
for Armenia, that it was
produced at Glandsor,
but in 1311 when the monastery
was in contact with Silesia.
And Evalion suggests
in the catalogue
that the Nativity displays the
"may chi" [phonetic]
in Mongol dress.
If so, it may be that by
the early 14th century,
Armenians profiting
by controlling Mongol trade
routes solve the Mongols
to their east, and as positive
a light as this image suggests.
As research expands on the work
done in the exhibition catalogue
by a variety of authors, with
most especially Rachel Costaryan
on the Armenian wealth,
derived from being a power
on Mongol trade routes, I
think other issues will arise.
And one of interest to me is
whether the Silesian Armenians,
who moved to the Crimea,
which was under Mongol,
rule as the Mongols
devastated their own country,
move there as a deliberate
choice
to maintain their trade
routes with the Mongols,
even as the extent of the
"Pox Mongolica" declined.
I hope this brief
introduction to the question
of the Mongol impact of
the wealth of Silesia
and Mongol great control
of Greater Armenia will
encourage further research
into the role of the
Armenians as a power
on Mongol trade routes.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank You, Dr. Evans, I think
that actually is a brilliant
introduction to what I said
that there's so much
left to be studied
and produced in Armenian
history.
Our next speaker is someone who
is not unknown to the Library
of Congress and to the
region, Dr. Amy Landau.
She is at the -- she is the
director of cultural affairs
and curator of Islamic and
South and Southeast Asian art
at the Walters Art
Museum in Baltimore.
And if you have not been
there I really urge you to go
to see the splendors, and not
just the Armenians splendors.
Dr. Landau will speak on
a concert of luxury wares
and estates, the will
of the 17th century
Armenian merchants Po-hos
[inaudible] Anyang.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Can you all hear me?
I would like to begin by
warmly thanking LaVon to return
to some old friends who I'll
talk about today, and also to be
in the company of good friends.
And I hope to welcome all of
you to the Walters Art Museum,
it's only 45 minutes away.
We honor, preserve and
celebrate great collection
of Armenian art there,
and I still look forward
to a future collaboration
between the Walters
and the Library of Congress.
So, my talk today pivots around
a document of great interest
for early modern Armenian
patronage and collecting.
It is the will of Jota
Pohos Vallejanian.
Pohos was a Zion of one
of the wealthiest
Armenian merchant families
of 17th century Iran.
His will is dated 1062
of the Islamic calendar,
which translates as
1646 of our Common Era
and it was amended
seven years later.
The will was originally
written in Persian,
and his bequest was
translated into Armenian
by the 19th century historian
Ter of Hanians, to be included
in that authors "Pat
Mattoon Nor Juhaiu",
or "History of New Julfa".
Ter of Hanians oversaw the
archives of Sorb Amana Parchik,
was a great archivist
and historian,
like our dear friend LaVon,
and he wrote his extraordinary
useful history published
in 1880, primarily on
the basis of Persian
and Armenian documents
preserved at the cathedral.
Poho's will, with its
really dizzying list
of palatial estates,
vineyards, shops,
gold and silver tableware,
carpets, porcelain,
provides a rare view of
the vast possessions owned
by Armenian elites
residing in Safavid, Iran.
This document excites
me as an art historian,
since it offers concrete
evidence of the sizable,
financial and physical
wealth of Armenian merchants,
who were also major
patrons of Arts.
We often reference
the enormous wealth
of Armenian merchants patrons
but rarely do we know the
details of their assets,
which are provided
in Poho's will.
In its dazzling enumeration
of properties, objects
and textiles, Poho's will
offers a platform for us
to discuss the amassment
of possessions both local
and foreign that I believe
was key to the identity
of 17th century Armenians.
Surplus wealth was constantly
communicated by Polos,
his family and other
Armenian resort merchants,
residing as Kristyn Dime
that has protected
religious minorities
within the Safavieh Empire.
Pohos' lists of luxury wears
and estates prompts us to think
about Armenian patrons
as great collectors
of the early modern
world, and it has pushed me
to consider our medium
merchants,
not just as devout patrons, but
also as voracious collectors.
Compared with scholarship
on early modern European
collecting,
there has not been thorough
investigation of collecting,
collections and collectors
in Iran.
Within the sphere of Persian
and collecting practices,
scholarship has tended
to focus on aggregations
of specific media, such as
arts of the book and porcelain.
Manuscripts and ceramics,
however, they were intended --
they were intended to
be seen and enjoyed
with other valuable objects,
resulting in "collections
of collections", according to
Hoary Twatsea, or "a concert
of things" as described
by Stefan Weber.
Drawing upon the will of Pohos,
in association with other texts
and images of the period,
such as these beautiful
life-sized oil paintings were
seeing in front of us, I'm
starting to explore the amassing
of luxury items in association
with the accumulation
of properties to understand
how various objects,
such as clocks Mira's,
Italian red velvet and glass,
placed in architectural
surrounds, all worked in concert
to express a carefully
constructed Armenian identity,
a successful merchant,
worldly collector
and devout community member.
So, let me begin by just
giving you a taste of the will,
and as you could all see,
and this is just
the will's preamble.
"Before a Council, Khwaja
Polos, son of Khwaja Petros,
son of Kwaja Velijanean
willfully
and with complete rationality
bequeaths, to his sons Hacobjan
and Hovhanjan, and their mother
Murasay, daughter of Voskan,
all his possessions of which
he himself has ownership,
either considerable
or inconsiderable,
ready cash or possessions.
That is, domestic movables,
vessels, table-cloths, rugs,
carpets, thick felts, clothing,
household utensils, goldware,
silverware, copperware,
enamelware" --
which was probably definitely
imported, "precious stones,
chinaware, livestock, purchased
slaves", and then he goes
on to describe all
the four-legged beasts
that he owned.
"Landed property, vineyards,
houses", and the list goes on.
And it concludes, "whether it be
credit, charitable capital" --
and here he uses the Islamic
term "waqf", "that he invested
in Julfa at Isfahan" a
place he had built and part
of which he had inherited, which
are now properties in his name.
So, as many of, you know,
Shah Abbas forcibly deported
the Armenians from Julfa.
So, Polos' amassed possessions
should be considered in light
of his being third generation
of the Velijanean
family in, Safavid, Iran.
According to Terhov Janean's,
Polos' grandfather
was from Haiajztan.
"I was among those who
were originally relocated
from Julfa", which you
probably saw on the map earlier.
As many of you know, again,
Julfa was on the
contested lands,
along the Ottoman-Safavid
border.
Shah Abbas the first
raised Julfa
and forcibly relocated
Julfa's residents,
who had already been
profiting from the sale of silk
through an extensive
trade network.
Due to their wealth and
mercantile connections,
Shah Abbas spared
Velijanean's community,
the hardships endured
by the less affluent Armenians,
and repositioned the Julfans
within his empire, at Esfahan,
close to the core and very close
to the commercial
center, and you have
to imagine this Maydan
just buzzing with merchants
and buyers in the 17th century.
New Julfa was purposely
built to house the Julfans
across the Zion Derude
river, the Zion Darude,
the river to the
south of Isfahan.
By the time Polos' father
was an active member
of the New Julfa
community, the Velijanean's,
along with the suburbs
other merchant families,
were profiting tremendously
from selling Iranian silk
across the globe,
through a network
of New Julfan satellite
communities.
Representatives of the
main wealthy families
of Julfa were representing the
Julfan families abroad in South,
Southeast Asia, East
Asia, Russia and Europe.
And, of course, we have
all this information
from wonderful economic
historians who are working
on New Julfa at the moment,
in the past ten years.
Surplus wealth went
into construction --
constructing an awesome
built environment.
Through a network of bridges
New Julfa became an extension
of Isfahan's palace precinct.
The quarters of Isfahan,
inhabited by the Muslim
political elite, were connected
to the most beautiful
Armenian houses of Julfa,
a suburb of Isfahan through
a network of bridges,
such as the one you're
seeing here.
In Terhov Anians' history,
in the chapter dedicated
to the Velijanians, he
immediately links Velijan with
"Sorb Bethlehem" or
"Holy Bethlehem",
the most stately domed church
built during the initial decades
following the transportation
of the Julfans from Julfa
to New Julfa, in
Juha to Nor Juha.
Throughout this church,
one can find the name
of Polos and his family.
Petros, who founded this
glorious Church in 1628,
and now we're going to
see a picture of Petros,
located in the congregation
area of the church.
Here we see Petros
wearing a dress analogous
to the Muslim political
and economic elite.
He's wearing the fur line
vest and patterned headdress,
the fur probably
imported from Russia
where the Armenians had very
close ties around the 1660s.
And he rests his hand
on the Holy Gospel,
and in the other hand, I
believe he's holding a fair mon.
So, a decree issued
by the Safavid Court,
which gives this Dime, this
Christian minority the ability
to build a religious
structure in Isfahan.
The bequest of Polos
makes frequent reference
to this church, and this church
is located in the Great Square
of New Julfa called
Mezmaydan, "the Great Maydan".
17th century visitors, as well
as our 19th century
historian Terhov Haneans,
has written that Polos and
his father Petros were highly
regarded for their massive
investment in this great square,
which was really the
commercial heart of the suburb.
And here I quote Terhov
Hanians who writes,
"especially its homes, its
beautifully laid out shops
and its magnificent Church".
I'd like to pause on the overall
effect of Bethlehem Church,
which is decorated with
European-style murals,
and here Bethlehem is actually
the first church to be decorated
with these Europeanized
murals so, we have to think
of the Velijanean
family as really ushering
in this new mode referred to
as "ferein ushazi" in Isfahan.
So, one, as we all know at this
point, many of us have worked
on this, the wall paintings
in the church are based
on prints -- will
ultimately derive from prints,
"Evangelicae Historiae
Magnus", and this was printed
in the late 16th
century and Antwerp
and it had many different
iterations throughout the
17th century.
But we really have to
see, we've been focusing
on these wall paintings,
but we have to see the
entire structure in concert.
So, we have to look at the
portrait, the paintings,
the gilded stucco
and the cobble tiles
with yellow inscriptions just
really pronouncing the name
of Petros, Polos
and their family.
And we have to imagine
this building covered
in beautiful silk carpets,
embroidered with metallic thread
and with Pope's -- with
Popes, sorry about that,
that was a bad mistake.
But [laughter] with
priests processing
in such glorious copes
as the one you see here,
which actually the members
of Victorian Albert Museum have
found an Armenian inscription
in this cloak.
Adjacent to this church --
so, we have to think
of entering this church
as a sensory experience,
and when the visitor leaves
the church, there is a plethora
of shops that are
also associated
with Polos and his family.
The French traveler Jean
Baptiste Tavernier writes,
"the beautiful square in which
the market is held is entirely
surrounded by shops,
it's another of the works
for which the public is beholden
to Petros, Polos' father,
and which render his memory
famous among the Armenians".
The will also continue to
list all the other shops,
not just in New Julfa but
in other suburbs of Isfahan.
Well, the request
statement does not say.
We may assume that the
various shops owned
by Polos sold both
local and foreign goods.
Although the Safavid Court
unilaterally commissioned
European merchants to obtain
foreign items for them,
it was the Armenians who
really had the lion's share
of the market as
importers of European
and Russian luxury wares.
Importation of foreign goods
by Armenian merchants is
really well documented,
and we see reference to this
in these two oil
paintings in front of us.
Venetian glass, Italian
red velvet,
enamelware, European clocks.
Reading through the latter part
of the will, one is astounded
by the sheer number of
properties owned by Polos.
The document lists houses in
New Julfa and, as I mentioned,
other suburbs of Isfahan.
They were built close to the
church and close to the shops,
but we also have to think
about all these houses
being built next
to other important patrons of
New Julfa, such as the family
of Tsar Fras and the
family of Abbatik.
Abbatik -- the reference to
Abbatik may be the individual
who was part of the commission
of the cathedral, Amana Parkich.
Clearly ownership of property
was a good investment.
Traditionally land
ownership in the Middle East
in Europe was the
basis of wealth.
Houses were assets that
could be used or bequeathed
by family members
and there is evidence
that the domestic properties
were even rented out.
Aside from the economic
benefits, however,
I'd like to point out
the sociological aspect
to the amassment of properties.
And for comparison we
could look to the Jews
of the Ottoman Empire.
New Julfa, merchants who were
also "outsiders", quote-unquote,
as a relocated Dimmi community,
desire to show their communal
investment and their ties,
their location to their
built environment.
Within these spaces, these
public and private spaces,
affluent Armenian families like
the Velijaneans, received --
they welcomed into their
house Armenian, European,
Russian merchants, as well as
members of foreign embassies,
including ambassadors.
This is especially true
of the public areas
of palatial estates, and 17th
century sources are replete
with references to visits on
behalf of the Safavids Court.
We know through the good
work of Cara Pettean
that the Velijaneans
owned a house, a mansion,
that in one room was decorated
with the eight wonders
of the world so, that's
an additional one.
And much work needs to be done
on interpreting why they felt
that these eight
wonders were important.
They probably derived from
Hemskirk, a printed source.
And also we could
assume that in the houses
of the Velijaneans they
had life-size oil paintings
such as the ones were
seeing before us.
A number of these survived
and they're seen in situ
and the few mansions
of the Armenians
that survived in
New Julfa today.
What are we looking at?
So, here we're looking
at single figures
in these fantastic
European-style interiors.
The columns are decorated
with Pucci, the ballast rod
and the claw leg-type table
are all service backdrops
and basically they're riffing
off of royal portraiture
that is being circulated
throughout Iran,
and here we see Louis
XIII and Anne of Austria.
And on the right hand side --
no, yes, on your left
hand side we see an urn
that is probably drawn
from a printed source.
They're really fantastical,
imagined objects
that European artists
are circulating in Iran.
And what -- these
are not individuals
that are being depicted --
they are types, and they're what
type they are is communicated
by the details of
dress and head wear.
And Cornelius Debruyne documents
one of the elite Armenian women,
and just look closely -- and
I don't need to describe it
for you, but if you look
at her specific head wear
and gold coins hanging down
from it, it was created
to make a great impression.
So, the luxury goods depicted,
they speak to both
the realities,
as well as the aspirations of
Armenian mercantile elites.
The wine tape -- the wine
decanter on the table
on the long stem glass,
they've been identified
as venetian manufacture and
the stopper of the decanter
in the form of the three
eagle head is believed
to be a Russian design.
And I already mentioned her
coat, red velvet, is a reference
to Italian manufacturer
and we also find references
to Italian red velvet in
Persian sources of the period.
So, let's just recall the
list in Polos' request.
The silverware, the china, the
carpets, the enamels and more.
Polos like other members
of the Safavid elite amassed
a significant collection
of luxury items.
The desire to assemble
diverse objects
in this massive quantity, which
is enumerated in this will,
was shared by the Safavid Court
and by other Armenian families.
And these individuals
were all mutually invested
in imparting this image
of really unlimited wealth
and opulence, in a
17th century context.
The emphasis is usually
on foreign goods,
and there was an
investment, actually,
to maintain the foreign
nature of goods
by not making certain
things like enamels locally,
but importing them
abroad, from abroad.
And that ability to own
foreign items became a privilege
of the court and the Armenians.
It became a sign of class
and social differentiation.
I believe that the amassment
of luxury wares and domiciles
on behalf of the Armenians
like Polos was driven
by this common impulse, a desire
to maintain a privileged social
and economic standing
in the Safavid Empire.
Objects and architecture worked
in concert as an expression
of lifestyle, taste
and the knowledge
of worlds well beyond
Safavid, Iran.
According to Dimmi Law, New
Julfa's Armenians were to be
of lower social standing
and political stratum
than their Muslim peers.
Their ready access of cash,
however, allowed these merchants
to build and buy beautiful
homes and wonderful things
to decorate them with.
This conspicuous consumption
signaled membership and thus off
of it upper class,
including an association
with the Persian court.
Polos' is request -- the
quest gives an immediate
and firsthand description
of the numerous houses
and the luxury items that
were used to furnish them.
There must be more documents
like this and I'm looking
to my colleagues in the field to
work on them and to publish them
because only then will we
actually know the enormous
wealth that these
Armenians of New Julfa had,
and we need to analyze exactly
what objects are coming in
and how foreign and local
goods are working together
in the houses of New
Julfa, which still remain
to be documented in full.
I thank you for your attention
[ Applause ]
>> All right, thanks
Jamie Landau.
This, both Dr. Evans and Dr.
Landau's paper reminds me
of another point that needs to
be made, which is the influence
of Armenia on its neighbors and
the influence of the neighbors
on Armenia, both of those papers
give wonderful examples of that.
And also the fact that
everyone you are listening
to today is an active
researcher in archives and user
of digital collections,
and that's another point
to be made by their papers.
And that also brings me to a
dear friend, a colleague of mine
at Columbia studied under
Nina Garzion, who will speak
on some beloved manuscripts
of ours here in the Library
of Congress and elsewhere.
I speak of Sylvie
Merion, who is at --
and I have got to get
this absolutely correct,
is at the Pierpont
Morgan Museum and --
>> Morgan Library and Museum.
>> Library and Museum.
And is an expert on all
things related to Book Arts,
manuscript arts and
illuminations,
and today she will speak to
us on the eclectic nature
of late Armenian manuscripts
from Constantinople, Dr. Merion.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much, LaVon,
for that nice introduction
and for inviting me, and also
for all the wonderful things
you've done in the decades now.
OK, can everybody hear me?
All right.
OK, I just want to see
how does this work, OK.
OK so, Armenians have a long
history in Constantinople.
Their presence in the city
has been attested to since
at least the 4th,
5th century AD.
Ongoing political upheavals
in Anatolia over many,
many centuries generated
increasing Armenian emigration
across Byzantine lands
into the capital Byzantium,
later called Constantinople
and its temple.
After the collapse of
the Byzantine Empire
with the Ottomans gaining
control of the capital city
in 1453, Armenian emigration
to Constantinople continued.
So, I'm not going to go
over this map too much
because we've already seen one,
but I have circled areas
I'm going to talk about.
But one thing I do
want to mention is
that in Armenian Kalla funds,
which I will explain a
little more in a second,
they refer to Constantinople
by many different names,
including Byzantium.
So, in 17th century manuscripts
they're still calling the city
"Byzantium" sometimes.
So, we have Byzantium,
Constantinople,
Istanbul or Bolis or Stambul.
And the circled areas are places
I'm going to be talking about.
The earliest Armenian Church
in Constantinople is St.
Sarkis, known since 1360.
By the 17th century, a large
Armenian community was present
in Constantinople with many
churches to serve them.
Manuscript Calafunds indicate
that numerous scriptoria
in the capital were still
producing high quality,
luxury manuscripts, both
on paper and on parchment,
which is animal skin
at this time,
and I want to explain
what a colophon is,
it's an inscription written
by the scribe who's
copied the manuscript,
usually put at the end of the
manuscript saying, "I did this,
please pray for me, the
miserable scribe Hagop,
I need your prayers, even
though I don't deserve anything"
and he will tell you where he
made the manuscript, the date
and give you a lot of
historical information and a lot
of information about
his family and anyone
who worked on this manuscript.
So, they're very important
for historical research also.
And so, I will be mentioning
the word "colophon" a lot.
All right so, three
churches or manuscripts
with scriptoria are
frequently named
as being the places the
manuscripts were produced.
Saint Nicholas, St. Sarkis
the general and St. Gevorg
or St. George, also called
"Sulumanastij" in Turkish,
and sometimes the
Armenians also use the word
"Suleimanasteed"
in the colophon.
The production of
manuscripts in the 17th
and 18th centuries was not
unique to Armenians, however.
In Christian, Muslim and Jewish
traditions throughout the Near
East, manuscripts
continued being created
until the 18th and
19th centuries.
By Western standards,
this is very strange
and surprisingly late.
I should also mention that in
Western manuscripts you usually
don't have a colophon.
If you have it, you will have
something to the effect of,
"this was copied
by Joe", that's it.
We have pages and pages
and pages of information
through colophons in the
Armenian tradition, OK.
So, Armenian scribes,
artists and bookbinders
at this time continued making
manuscripts at this late date,
using traditional methods
and skills, passed on to them
by their masters, using
parchment at times,
copying the manuscripts by hand
and painting the eliminations,
and binding the books using
long-established techniques.
They were, however, receptive
to new ideas, techniques
and iconography brought
to them through contact
with neighboring peoples
or European traditions,
as we shall see.
Now, why were these cultures
in the Near East still
producing manuscripts
in the 17th and 18th centuries?
By this time in Europe, printed
books had long overtaken the
production of manuscripts, but
this Western European technology
of printing, which
began around 1455
with Gutenberg's
printing press in Europe,
was not readily available
in the near East.
It would take time to import
the technology, equipment
and expertise needed, and even
longer for it to become accepted
and widespread due to
technological issues, funding
and censure, for example,
by Ottoman authorities.
Indeed the first printed books
in Armenian, Greek, Hebrew,
and Arabic were all
produced in Europe.
The first printed book in the
Armenian language was printed
in Venice, Italy around 1511 or
1512, a modest book of prayers
and spells, particularly useful
to travelers and merchants,
and you see a copy
of this book here.
An Armenian printing press was
established in Constantinople
as early as 1567, but it only
functioned for two years.
Armenian presses would not be
reestablished there until 1677,
and that press only produced
two books and lasted one year.
Ottoman authorities would not
officially permit printing
in the Empire until 1727.
However, Armenian
books were printed
in Europe throughout the
17th centuries in cities
such as Amsterdam, Marseilles,
Livorno and Louvre of Poland,
which were -- and these books
were exported to the Near East,
but clearly not in the quantity
which met the needs
of the community.
It is therefore not surprising
that scriptoria were still
busily producing superb medieval
style manuscripts well into
the 17th and 18th centuries.
Consequently, for centuries,
Armenian printed books
and Armenian manuscripts
were produced simultaneously
and influenced each other.
By this -- next slide,
there we go.
By the 17th century,
Armenian manuscripts
in Constantinople enjoyed
an undeniable renown
and luxury manuscripts
were commissioned
from Constantinopolitan
scriptoria from distant regions.
This unusual luxury
manuscript Bible
on parchment was
commissioned in 1607
by the wealthy Armenian
merchants Hojin Nazar,
who New Julfa, Iran, an affluent
Armenian suburb of Isfahan,
the capital of the
Iranian Safavid empire.
It was completed in
Constantinople in 1623
and delivered to
Hojin Nazar in 1629.
Note that the complete Bible
in the Armenian language would
not exist in printed form
until it was printed
in Amsterdam in 1666.
So, before 1666 if
you wanted a Bible
in the Armenian language you
had to have it copied by hand.
This Bible with Genesis
scenes in roundels --
it doesn't work on
the thing -- OK.
On this side you see
the round circles.
It had -- these are Genesis
scenes along with the story
of Adam and Eve in the
three registers below,
uses iconography borrowed
from Europe and found
in manuscripts -- European
manuscripts from the mid-9th
to the 15th centuries.
It is highly unlikely -- and I
would say probably impossible,
however, that Armenians
in Constantinople had any direct
access to such manuscripts,
and we have not yet determined
the exact sources they used.
In any case, this type
of Genesis frontispiece became
a popular model for a group
of 17th century Armenian Bibles.
They exist in at least ten
Armenian manuscripts made
in Constantinople and
later in New Julfa.
This sumptuous example of
a parchment Synnex Aryan,
which is a book of saints lives,
was specially commissioned
from Constantinople
by Vartavet Sarkis,
the head of the Armenian
Monastery
of St. Macarius and
Nicosia Cyprus.
Perhaps there was no scriptorium
in Nicosia with scribes
or artists capable of producing
such a lavish manuscript,
or perhaps there was no exemplar
from which to copy in Nicosia.
We should note, again, that the
Armenian Synnex Aryan did not
exist in a printed
version until 1706.
So, if you needed one for
your church, monastery
or private use before 1706,
there was no other solution
than to have one
copied by scribe.
Armenian artists
and Constantinopolitan
scriptoria worked
in two distinguishable styles.
Both approaches look back
at their solution for bears,
especially for decorative
elements.
One employed a more classical
style, constituting a kind
of Silesian, revival
mixed with elements drawn
from Western European
and Byzantine art.
This manuscript, a
gospel dated 1643,
exemplifies this more
classical style in the portrait
of the Evangelist
Matthew on the left.
On the right is the first
page of Matthew's Gospel,
and we note that his symbol,
an angel, has been twisted
to form the first
letter of the text.
So, that angel there is actually
the letter Kim in Armenian.
The symbols of the evangelists
twisted into letters --
the angel, lion, ox
or eagle has been used
since the Silesian period
in Armenian iconography.
The intricate decoration
of the headpiece as well
as the marginal design
on the right,
are typical of traditional
manuscript illumination.
The headpiece is the archway
the on the right-hand page,
and of course you see that
very beautiful fancy decorative
marginal design.
Another traditional
characteristic
of Armenian illuminated
gospel books was
to include sumptuously decorated
Canon tables, which are kind
of indexed to the four Gospels.
The example on the left is from
a mid-17th century gospel book
from Constantinople at the
Morgan, and it's compared
with one from the 12th
century, on the right.
The importance of Canon tables
is emphasized by the fact
that at least three Armenian
medieval commentaries were
written to explain the symbolism
of these usually
lavishly decorated pages.
The most famous of these
commentaries was written
by the 12th century
Catholicos St. Nersesh Norhali.
Catholicos, for those who may
not know, is the supreme head
of the Armenian church
and Nersesh Norhali
was also a theologian,
poet and composer of hymns.
In his treatise he
discussed the importance
of lavish cannon tables, as
a visual aid to meditation,
calling them "baths
of sight and hearing
for those approaching the
soaring peaks of God".
17th century Armenian
artists from many regions --
not just Constantinople,
continued to illustrate cannon
tables in a similar manner
as an homage to their
ancestral traditions.
This is an example
of the second style
of manuscript illumination
used in Constantinople,
which developed in the second
half of the 17th century.
This style was characterized
by figures outlined in strong,
black lines with
prominent noses and the use
of mostly flat planes of
color, sometimes abstracted
as we see here on the left.
And I particularly like
the water shown here.
It's very, very abstract
and actually very
modern, to my eyes.
The unnamed artists of
this manuscript, however,
still looks back to Armenian
traditions for the decoration
of the headpiece and the
intricate marginal designs.
You see the marginal designs
on both images and,
again, the headpiece.
[ Applause ]
These three manuscripts
exemplify this later style
of Constantinopolitan
manuscripts, as demonstrated
in the works of the
artists Markos Badgerahan,
which means "portrait painter",
which is a very unusual epithet
for an artist to use,
and his son Gabriel.
Manuscripts by Markos
date from 1651 to 1694.
Gabriel was certainly
trained by his father.
An early Salter by Markos
is on the left dated 1659.
Father and son sometimes
worked together,
as in the Alexander romance
in the center, done in 1694
when Markos was elderly.
It was copied by Gabriel,
who also informs us
through the Colophon that
he painted the pictures,
but that his father
decorated it.
By this he probably means that
Markos had a more minor role
in illustrating this manuscript.
The manuscript on the right is
illustrated by Gabriel alone,
who now informs us that
his father has died.
The stylistic connections
between the two men are obvious.
We can see the small
black dots for eyes,
strong black lines outlining the
nose, eyebrows and the figures,
and two lines to
indicate the mouth.
Gabriel, however, has taken
these features even further
in his handling of bold lines.
This manuscript, a complete
Bible, was produced in 1647
in Constantinople,
in a scriptorium
under the jurisdiction
of St. Nicholas Church.
This manuscript was
copied on parchment,
made from animal skin.
Done in what we're calling
"the classical style" with --
however with a lot
of unusual features.
This is the beginning of the
Psalms, with the repentant David
on the left traditionally
believed
to be the author of the Psalms.
David kneels while looking
up at a chastising angel,
who holds a skull, three
switches and a sword.
These represent the punishments
that God has demanded
David choose
in retribution for his sins.
Famine, war or plague.
The skull represents the
ultimate outcome of any
of these punishments, death.
This iconography is not
Armenian, it has been borrowed
from Western Europe
through the vehicle
of an imported illustrated
printed book not yet identified.
The facing, intricate page
includes a traditional Armenian
back headpiece and
marginal decoration,
with traditional Armenian
decorative bird letters.
So, the first letter of text
there is actually letters
forming words made
of twisted birds,
sometimes they also
like to use fish.
However, the vase of
flowers under the arch
of the headpiece is
something quite different.
The artist of this
manuscript seems
to have been enamored
with flowers.
Here is another example
of a vase of flowers
under a traditional
headpiece and there are many,
many others in this manuscript,
I could do a whole lecture just
on this manuscript, but I can't.
We're not allowed.
Not only are they -- the
flowers used in headpieces
as we just saw, but they are
also scattered throughout this
Bible as a framing device for
the portrait busts of authors
of various books of the
Bible, and there are dozens
of similar floral portraits
throughout this manuscript.
Another unusual characteristic
of this Bible concerns
the decoration
of the book of Revelation.
Before the 17th century,
Armenian manuscripts
of the complete Bible -- which
were not very common anyway,
they did not illustrate the
apocalypse with anything more
than perhaps an author
portrait of John.
After the 17th century,
through exposure
to imported European printed
and illustrated books,
they began illustrating
the book of Revelation
by copying European
woodcuts and engravings,
as there really was
no Armenian tradition
of illustrating Revelation.
In a few cases we have been able
to identify the exact
printed source.
In this case I have found
the type of engraving used
as a model, ultimately
derive from Dirar.
This etching and the Armenian
elimination depict a literal
illustration of Revelation
chapter ten, verses one to 11,
and I'll read it
first two lines.
"And I saw another mighty
angel coming down from heaven,
wrapped in a cloud, with
a rainbow over his head.
His face was like the sun and
his legs like pillars of fire.
He held a little scroll, open in
his hand, setting his right foot
on the sea and his
left on the land,
he gave a great shout
like a lion roaring".
And in this case the left
and right legs were reversed
in both the engraving and
the Armenian illumination
shown here.
Oops. I'm getting
ahead of myself.
Exposure to all types
of European printed books
had a great influence
on Near Eastern artists
of the 17th century.
Not only European religious
books, but also books
like printed herbals, which
would have been replete
with plant and floral images.
And not just Armenian
artists, as we shall soon see.
In the 18th century
when Christians, Muslims
and Jews were still making
manuscripts, things start
to change even more drastically.
This exposure to new motifs
would have a strong effect
on book decoration, as well as
other art forms, and would bring
about important changes in taste
and style in the Ottoman Empire,
as well as elsewhere in the
Near East including Iran.
Now, before I get to
18th-century manuscripts,
I want to just first
show you the bindings
of a couple Armenian
manuscripts and.
yes, these are two
Armenian manuscripts.
The binding on the left
is typically Armenian
in both decoration
and technique,
which were used for centuries.
So, I should just briefly
explain different cultures have
different ways of
making their books
and have different
techniques of sewing
and making their
manuscripts, OK?
So, the library -- this, the one
on the left is a
typical Armenian example.
The Library of Congress example
on the right is an Armenian
Christian manuscript,
but has been bound in a
typical Islamic binding,
probably Turkish but
could possibly be Persian.
It is Islamic in both decoration
and technique of binding.
Now I'm going to discuss
this very interesting Library
of Congress manuscript
at length now.
Upon opening the book with the
Islamic binding, we first note
that it is handwritten
in Armenian,
and also that the first
page is a title page.
Now, this is unusual because
title pages were common
in printed books but
not in manuscripts.
This book is an apocryphal
Christian text,
the acts of St. John the
Evangelist, and we are provided
with a date, 1214 in the
Armenian era but written
with Arabic numerals, instead
of the Armenian alphabet used
as numerals, which
would have been normal
and which is how he gives
the date in the Colophon.
This date, 1214, is equivalent
to 1214 plus 551 AD, 1765.
The next page depicts a portrait
of St. John the Evangelist,
but the style is
much more European.
Notice the gentle
modeling of the face
and there's a much better
understanding of perspective,
especially evident in rendering
the checkerboard floor,
something else not commonly
seen in Armenian manuscripts.
The facing page of texts
includes bird letters,
and a decorative headpiece
typical in Armenian manuscripts,
but there is nothing typical
in its decorative scheme.
It is filled with
naturalistic flowers instead
of the usual Armenian
motifs, as we just saw,
and a traditional marginal
design is placed on the right
but has been transformed
by using flowers.
As we go through the book, we
note first that it is paginated,
again, using Arabic numerals,
something not normally
done in a manuscript.
It's possible that these numbers
could have been added later
but the paleography appears
very similar to the numerals
on the title page,
and I'm convinced
that the scribe wrote
all of them.
They are carefully written on
each page within the gold box.
More startling is
that the beginning
of each chapter is embellished
with a naturalistic flower.
LaVon Abdoyan has informed me
that he had a botanist
colleague look at these images,
who confirmed that not all
of them are real plants.
There's often something
wrong, for example,
certain flowers supposed to have
six petals and the artist did it
with eight or something
like that.
But they certainly were painted
in an extremely naturalistic
manner.
In spite of all these
unusual characteristics --
and there are more, which I
don't have time to get into,
the manuscript includes
a traditional
and lengthy Armenian
colophon, from which we learned
that it was completed in
1765 by the scribe artist,
notary and flower
painter, Havanes of Becos,
son of Madeiro Simonian.
Becos is a district
of Constantinople.
The person who commissioned
and paid
for this luxurious
manuscript was Bouhaus Amira,
son of Medeiros Jovian, grandson
of Mahtesi Harukun Amira.
And Amira is an Armenian
honorific title for a group
of wealthy people
who were leaders
of the Armenian Ottoman
Millette and favored
by the Ottoman government.
The colophon does
not specifically say
where the manuscript
was produced.
The scribe and artist just
tells us that he is of Becos,
not specifically that
it was made in Becos.
Theoretically this could mean
that the manuscript could
have been produced elsewhere.
But for reasons I will explain,
I believe that it was produced
in Constantinople,
perhaps in Becos itself.
So far, I have found one
other manuscript made
by the same scribe an
artist Havanes of Bakos.
This 1762 copy of
the book of prayer
by the beloved 10th-11th
century Armenian mystic
and saint Gregory of Notic.
It is extremely similar to the
Library of Congress manuscript.
This is the beginning of
the text, with a portrait
of the author, St.
Gregory on the left,
and the highly decorated
headpiece
and marginal decoration on the
facing page composed, again,
of flowers, as we saw in the
Library of Congress manuscript.
And note again, the
checkerboard floor.
The person who commissioned
this manuscript, as we're told
in the colophon was
Mahtesi Haruchun,
son of Mathesi Alexan
Amira, again,
a wealthy Armenian
from Constantinople.
This is the other full-page
illumination in this manuscript,
St. Gregory kneeling
before the Virgin and Child,
who holds a tiny
book in his hands
which had been symbolically
presented
to Christ by the author.
This the front cover of the
knotting manuscript with, again,
a Turkish style binding.
And the manuscript also includes
the same type of flowers
in the margins as we saw
in the previous example,
and neither this
knotting manuscript
or in the previous
acts of Saint John,
does the text discuss flowers.
These flowers are placed here
simply for the visual pleasure
of the viewer, not because
they are illustrating something
discussed in the text.
Now Havanes of Becos was
not the only Armenian artist
in 18th century Constantinople,
who was enamored with flowers.
There are many examples of
late Armenian manuscripts
with this type of decoration.
The artist of this 1770 missile
from Constantinople has
filled the headpiece
and marginal design
with flowers.
This secular manuscript,
a history by the 12th century
author Samuel of Unny was copied
in Constantinople in 1777
by the scribe Nickohios.
The artist is not named
but it's very probable
that the flower painter was
Havanes of Bekos himself,
as it is extremely
similar to those
in the two manuscripts
we saw earlier
that we know he produced,
and we know for sure this
is from Constantinople.
The floral decoration
has nothing to do
with this historical text.
Again, a decorative motif
used to embellish the text
for the visual enjoyment
of the reader.
This example is from a text
called "The city of Troy
and it's Kings" by
Nicholaios Lucianos,
copied in Constantinople
in 1779 by the scribe
and translator Georg Dpir
Yovhannessian Palatetsi.
The artist is not
named in the colophon.
Note again the use of
decorative flowers,
painted in a very Rococo style,
especially as seen
in the headpiece.
Traditional Armenian decorative
marginal motifs, still common
in the mid-12th century,
have now been transformed
to a new floral concept
by the mid-18th century,
reflecting a general change
in taste in the region.
And not just with
Armenians, this fascination
with decorative flowers became
quite popular in the upper
and ruling classes
of the Ottoman Empire
in the 18th and 19th centuries.
This was a period of increasing
contact with Europeans,
as well as with their
material goods,
which would have an effect
on the artistic vocabulary
in the capital.
We now see similar
floral motifs even used
to embellish Turkish religious
manuscripts, such as this Quran
of 1798 on the left, and a
pious text from 1848 to '49
on the right, this one with an
even more Rococo style to it.
One of the most famous
examples of the use
of such ornamentation is
the so called "Fruit room"
of the Sultan's harem or
private family quarters
of the Topkapi Palace,
painted in 1705.
The Sultan at this time
was Ahmed the Third,
who reigned from 1703 to 1730
and under whose rule
there was much contact
with France and French
diplomats.
The walls and ceiling of
the fruit room are filled
with Rococo vases of
flowers, bowls of fruit
and floral sprays throughout.
On the right is another of --
is an official Ottoman document,
dated 1862 to 77,
the deed of endowment
of a later Sultan's
mother, again,
highly decorated
with floral motifs.
Because of the late advent
of printing in the Near East,
Armenian manuscripts were still
being produced in Constantinople
and elsewhere in the
17th and 18th centuries.
Scribes, artists and
bookbinders continued centuries
of uninterrupted Armenian
book art traditions,
even after books were
produced on a printing press.
However, as we have seen,
they also embraced new
developments derived
from imported European
printed books,
of which I only could speak
of a few, but they are --
and they are also reflected --
they also reflected local taste,
including new iconography,
increased interest
in perspective and
new decorative motifs.
The floral motifs, for instance,
were probably first introduced
through European printed
herbal or botanical books,
but were used in
manuscripts purely
for their decorative qualities.
In fact, floral mania
became ubiquitous
in the privileged strata
of the Ottoman Empire,
and was also used to decorate
late Turkish manuscripts
and even mural paintings
for the ruling class
and the wealthy elite
in the Capitol.
In Armenian 17th
and 18th-century manuscripts
we see continued reverence
for their native traditions,
combined with an openness
to borrowing, sharing
and absorbing cross-cultural
stylistic vocabularies,
resulting in these fascinating,
eclectic manuscripts.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> So, as a transition,
rapid transition
from the late Middle Ages to the
modern age but still in the art,
historical and sociological
sphere, is a good friend
and a person who has
been active in archives,
searching out some very
interesting material
on little-known subject and
that is Vazken Khatchig Davidian
from England, who is
finishing his dissertation
on this subject, and he will
be speaking on the image
of the migrant worker,
visualizing the Banduokh,
from Ottoman Armenia in late
19th century Constantinople.
[ Applause ]
>> LaVon, thank you.
I'm afraid I woke up
this morning and I'd sort
of lost my voice so,
it's sort of comeback,
I've been drinking
lots of hot water.
LaVon thank you so much
for organizing this
amazing gathering,
and having all of us here.
I thought with the first
three peoples I'd sort of died
and gone to art historical
heaven, and it's amazing
from wealth and patronage,
we're sort of moving to porters
in 19th century Constantinople.
So, there you go.
I just want to introduce
you to a few words just
in case you're not
familiar with them.
The first word is "Bantoukhd",
and I do use the Western
Armenian transliteration,
I don't apologize for
it because we're dealing
with late 19th century
Constantinople.
So, a Bantoukhd is
a migrant worker.
They're usually male young
men who basically leave family
and homeland and moved to
Constantinople to work.
So, my paper is really about
the bantoukhd in Constantinople.
"Bantkdoutioun" is a
phenomenon but it is also --
it is a really charged word
because there's a sense
of tragedy about
the whole thing.
So, someone goes
on bantkdoutioun,
it's all bad yearning
for home, etcetera.
So, it has negative connotations
and there's a whole genre
of bantoukhd songs as well
going back a few centuries.
A lot of the heart of the
bantoukhds that I'm going
to be dealing with
today, Hamals,
and Hamal means "Porter".
It comes from the
Arabic word "Hamala" I
which means "to carry".
The Armenian word
is "pairnagish".
So, most of the images you
will be seeing today will be
of porters, and the last word
I want to introduce you to --
Mercer, you probably know
it, is "Hayasdantsi".
But hayasdantsi, in the late --
in its late 19th century
Constantinople serving carnation
meant an Armenian who
came from Ottoman Armenia,
and a hayasdantsi
was a native of Van,
a native of Mush,
of Esroom, etcetera.
So, we understand -- when
we talk about hayasdan,
when I speak about Ottoman
Armenia or hayastan,
I'll be meaning not the
Republic today, it is Armenia
as it was understood
in those days.
And "dantsi" is a suffix that
denotes from a particular place.
So, a native form --
of Mush, for example,
would be a "Mushetsi",
from Mush and "Tsi".
So, there you go.
So, here we go.
See if this works.
"Hamals on the bridge at
Karakoy", by the respected
but now mostly forgotten Ottoman
Armenian artist Simon Hagopian,
1857-1921 is a rendering
of an everyday scene,
which sets for men instantly
identifiable as bantoukhds
and Hamals by trait, mid
conversation while suppressed
by an especially constructed
timber structure in the middle
of the Galata bridge, that links
the old city of Constantinople
to the dynamic commercial
hub of Karakoy
in the upscale quarter of Para.
In this contemporary
and familiar scene,
one that Hagopian would
have passed by daily,
the artist has situated these
rural transplants into the heart
of the urban megalopolis,
represented here
as an ambivalent space,
conjured through a band
of hazy brushstrokes
that rendered the unmistakable
outline of the Galata tower.
You can -- you can't really
see it very well, but --
I can see it here, but it's
just over the head of the
of the man on his own.
It's really hazy, and
the general skyline
of the European part of
the city recognizable.
Hagopian has utilized narrative
gesture with great care,
to imbue tension and charge
into the conversation.
To definitely communicate to the
viewer the unhappy state of mind
of the central figure.
At the right of the
image, conveying some form
of displeasure, to his three
fellow Hamals, who are listening
to the man's words with
great concentration.
With deft use of brushstroke,
the artist has skillfully
marked the minutest details
and captured movements, such
as the enquiring gestures
of the man's hands with
their protruding networks
of silver veins -- silver blue
wanes, and Callum's open palm.
Meanwhile, the sweat on his brow
and red sunburns neck evoke
years of relentless toil
on the streets of
Constantinople,
and the hard life
of the bekkiar.
"Bekkiar" is a Turkish word,
which means "single men".
A lot of these men were not
single, but they actually lived
in Constantinople in groups,
having left all their wives
and families back
in the old country.
So, bekkiar is a collective term
that actually denotes
these people.
And they lived in
hans, and a han --
or a ham is as an inn where
many of these people lived
in slum-like conditions,
separated from family
and away from their homelands.
The dirty rags, riddled with
holes and crudely patched
in places, all told their
distinct stories of poverty,
migration and hardship.
This is a thoroughly
modern image.
Its modernity explicit
in the meticulously
rendered ornate ironwork
of the bridges balustrade,
signifying the latest
achievements
of modern British engineering,
and further underlined
by the consciously photographic
frame employed by the artist.
Consider the striking
similarity of the frames adopted
by Hagopian and the
British photographer
and illustrator Wren Abel's
photographic image carriers
resting, reproduced
in the London Illustrated
newspaper black and white
on 2nd of January, 1897.
The published photograph further
confirms the meticulous care
with which Hagopian has rendered
each detail of the bridge,
the hamal's rest station and the
timber decking of its pavement.
Irrespective of this
compositional affinities
of Hagopian's painting,
with a view as observed
through the frame
of the camera lens,
we do not know whether the
artist had introduced --
had reproduced the
scene from a photograph,
a common practice employed by
several of his contemporaries,
or had sketched it in situ and
then executed in his studio.
The gritty naturalism of
Hagopian's representation
of a fleeting moment
on the bridge,
rather than a mere picturesque
ethnographic depiction
of an exotic group -- one of
the most visible and emblematic
of the imperial capital of
three types, the hamals,
in a timeless, oriental setting,
suggests instead a desire
for an honest artistic
engagement
by a non-western artist with
his own immediate environment.
This presentation will focus
on visual representations
of the figure of the bantoukhd,
by late 19th century
Constantinople Armenian artists
by promoting two main ideas.
Firstly, it will propose that
work such as Hagopian's "Hamals
on the bridge" that
addressed contemporary themes
of social concern and were
executed in a Western mode
of visual art production,
oil on canvas painting,
needs to be considered
within the milieu
of a particular Ottoman
Armenian incarnation of realism,
the major preoccupations
of which included the life
of the bantoukhd
in Constantinople
and the implications of the
phenomenon or bantkhdouioun
on -- from Ottoman Armenia.
Realism was a dominant
intellectual philosophy among
the city's reformist circles
during the final two decades
of the 19th century, and
associated most notably
with a group of journalists,
chroniclers
and other writer activists,
assembled around the influential
editor Arpier Arpiarian,
1851 -- 1908.
And the popular dailies
Arabic orient from 1884
in Hairenick Fatherland from
1891 to 1896, which he edited.
Such a position challenges
accepted nations
in Armenian historiography
that have hitherto presented the
so-called Constantinople realist
generation Bostahai Rabash
Sevunts a literary movement,
the sole domain of novelists,
essays and journalists.
Secondly, it will propose
that during the period
under consideration,
characterized
by the increasingly
stringent censorship controls
of the Abdul Hameed
the Second regime --
he reigned between 1876 and
1908-1909, and rising tensions
between the state and the
empires Armenian population,
where any articulation of
Armenian identity was perceived
as a threat, artists often
utilized allegory cloaked
beneath the fashionable
ethnographic sensibilities
of the day to convey messages,
which were often received
or projected by some
viewers as such,
in order to evade the scalpel
of the censor and represent
on canvas what could not
be published in print.
The phenomenon of bantkdoutioun
had already emerged
as a prominent preoccupation
of Ottoman army intellectuals
during the second half
of the 19th century.
For these intellectuals,
Ottoman Armenia
and bantkdoutioun
represented the two faces
of the same proverbial coin.
They believed economic
and structural improvement
in Ottoman Armenia would
stem the flow of migration.
To Mugarich Cremyan,
1820-1907, it was patriarch
of Constantinople between 1869
and 1873, and he was catholicos
after 1893 until his
death in Russian Armenia,
affectionately known as
Heinrich, "little father",
his disciple the bishop
Kaerkin Servantsidean,
1840-1892 both natives
of Ottoman Armenia --
they were both born in
Van, and a generation
of mid-19th century
writers and ethnographers,
bantkhdoutioun had meant the
tragic abandonment of the land.
They espouse the economic
development of Ottoman Armenia,
especially of its
agricultural sector,
and called for the
establishment of infrastructure,
the rule of law, security
of life and property
within the Imperial
Ottoman framework.
The editor and activist
Megerdich Portulalyan,
1848 to 1921, considered
bantkhdoutioun as sin.
The desertion of
homeland and denigration
of the Armenian name, for him
being a Hama was an insult
to being Armenian.
These sentiments
are at the heart
of the author Mardiros
Khatchmerian's "Life
of the Armenian bantoukhd",
"Geangye bantachtats",
published in 1876
in Constantinople.
Khatchmerian urged all
bantoukhds to return
to their half and
homes in Armenia,
"till its soil and
make it blossom".
Using romantic and
religious allegory,
Hachmeryan divided bantoukhd
into three categories, the good
or fortunate, "bantoukhd
pachtavor",
who diligently sent
money to their families
and ultimately returned home.
The wretched, "bantoukhd
tejvaj", who were exploited
and were ultimately
unsuccessful,
and those who disappeared
without care,
"bantoukhd anhop hiuhaireniats",
leaving destitute
families behind.
Unsurprisingly, it is a latter
category that is subjected
to his greater attention and
for whom his unconcealed aya
is reserved.
Meanwhile, the allegorical
image on the cover, the original
of which was conceived
in the 1840s in Paris
by the paduan artists and
engraver Michele Fanoli --
he was born in 1807,
he died in 1876,
and he was actually a
teacher, he was an art teacher
at the Muradian School in Paris.
And he was asked to
come up with his image
by Ivosovski's brother, the
archbishop Gabriel Ivosovski.
So, the image depicts the
desolate figure of a woman,
sitting for long among ruined
classical columns at the foot
of Mount Ararat, which had
from the mid-19th century --
this image has from the
mid-19th century onwards,
become the ubiquitous
personification
of the words of Armenia.
Bantkhdouioun abandoned
ruination,
abandonment ruination.
While emigrating for work was
certainly not a solely Ottoman
Armenian phenomenon, I mean,
other groups migrated
as well for work.
So, while this was not solely
an Armenian phenomenon,
the specific perception
of the tragic abandonment
of the homeland had an
especially powerful,
emotional resonance among them.
Similar artistic and
literary sponsors
to similar phenomena are absent
from the contemporary
artistic production
of other neighboring
Ottoman populations,
such as Kurds, Greeks and Turks.
So, the period they were
actually looking, at the 1880s
and the 1890s, if you go through
works by Ottoman Turkish,
Kurdish, Greek Levantine
artists,
you will never actually see this
kind of image, just like the one
that I actually showed
you earlier.
So, it is pretty unusual,
and it's pretty unique
among Armenians.
The two decades following the
Russo-Ottoman war of 1877-1878
and the Great Famine of Van
and its aftermath in 1880-1881,
as well as the Treaty of Berlin
and the toothless proposals
for reform, had experienced
an increase in the outflow
of migrants, mostly younger
able-bodied provincial males
from Ottoman Armenia, fueled
by socio-economic, inter-ethnic
and political tensions,
facilitated by the increasingly
regular steamship connections
between Trebizond and
other black sea ports,
and Constantinople.
So, before, they actually
walk from the villages
of Mush all the way
to Constantinople.
Now they only had to walk to
the Black Sea, catch a boat
and go to Constantinople.
The areas of Ottoman
Armenia from where emigration
to the capital was highest,
was a region without roads
and -- roads or railways.
It lacked infrastructure,
where subsistence farming was a
major form of economic activity.
The region was characterized
by economic stagnation,
physical insecurity,
social disorder
and the absence of
the rule of law.
By 1890, the editorial, a
practical suggestion called
"Zagan ara Charkma" published on
the 5th of May, 1890 in Arabelc,
claim that it is an accepted
truth, and in comparison
with the other peoples
of the Empire,
Armenians have the
largest number
of bantoukhds in Constantinople.
While estimated at 15,000 in the
1860s, the numbers were believed
to have exceeded 80,000 before
the 1894-1897 massacres.
Now, in a city of 1 million
that's a pretty extraordinary
number, it's a huge chunk
of the Armenian population.
But, of course, I'm
not arguing that all
of these people were actually
Hamals, is basically people
who had actually migrated from
Ottoman Anatolia and elsewhere
to Constantinople,
they were Armenian
and they were basically
bantoukhds.
In a really interesting article
recently I saw Robert Tatoian
had -- in Armenia it's
calculated about 15%
of the population -- of
the of the male population
of the Bitless Villi,
it actually had gone
on bantkhdoutioun,
which is a really,
really interesting figure.
So, I'm not quite sure.
Sort of, you know -- there's
a few sort of sources,
whether they can be
trusted or not, but again,
sort of if you actually
look at the source material,
it really does show that a huge
number of people did migrate.
And Constantinople was not the
only place they actually went
there, for example
the Sussmansees,
people from Sassoon, are known
to have particularly gone
to Halep, where they
actually worked as bakers.
So, among Aleppo
Armenians today,
the surname "Khazakosian"
will immediately suggest
that one's ancestors
actually came from Sassoon.
But we're really concentrating
on Constantinople, I digress.
To the urban Ottoman
army intellectual
of the realist generation,
from a vantage point of mid
to late 1880s and
1890s Constantinople,
Ottoman Armenia was a
distant land in the East
that most had never
seen or experienced,
yet imagined vividly
and idealized.
There was a huge, huge chunk of
literature, mostly ethnographic
that was actually
available to these people so,
they did imagine what
Armenia would have been like.
But, of course, it's
-- Armenia lived
in their imagination rather
than the actual sort of poverty
that was actually on the line.
However, the presence of
thousands of bantoukhds
on the streets of the imperial
capital provided a powerful
material counterpart
to any abstract notions
of Ottoman Armenia.
A real flesh-and-blood, physical
manifestation of the streets
of the imperial capital,
personified in the recognizable
form of the provincial migrant.
Most visible among the highest
Sansees were the thousands
of Hamals, mainly peasants
from the villages of the plain
of Mush, but also from
the province of Van,
who for centuries past had
come to Constantinople to work,
lived in slum-like, conditions
were organized into as esnaf.
An esnaf is it's a kind of
guild, it's a kind of union,
where people have a certain
profession group together,
and the esnad actually
looked after them.
It was it was a very
interesting organization.
The word "esnaf" means different
things at different points
in time, but you can sort of
imagine it as a kind of --
sort of workers union.
So, these migrants,
these bundles pass --
these hamals passed
on their work
from one generation to the next.
So, the father would
come work for five years,
go back home and send his son.
So, you basically have the
same family, sort of members
of the same families
sort of taking
on the previous generation's
position.
Hence, the surname Hamalian or
Hamalbashian is a pretty sort
of popular surname
among Armenians
from the Van region,
and the Mush region.
They were really
proud to be Hamals.
Being a being a Hamal was
actually being a porter,
it was quite a, sort of honored
sort of profession for them.
But, of course, Constantinople
Armenians looked at them
in a completely different
way, but we'll get to that.
The Armenian hold on the
profession in the city appears
to have strengthened after
sultan Mahmud the Second,
1808-1839, massacred and
expelled the Muslim Hamals
of the port, following the
last Janissary revolt of 1826.
The Armenian patriarch Garibay
the Third of Constantinople,
1823-1831, was ordered
to provide 10,000 men
as replacements for the killed
or expelled Muslim porters.
Instantly recognizable,
the Hamal of Constantinople had
already become an iconic figure.
The subject of fascination for
writers and artists, visitors
and locals throughout the 19th
century, there's a huge number
of orientalist texts,
travel literature where --
which would mythologize
the Armenian Hamal
of Constantinople.
They keep on repeating
the myth was sort of,
they saw these Armenian Hamals
carrying enormous pianos
on their backs up
mountains and, you know,
it's all these stories.
So, with the advent
of photography,
they became popular -- they
became a popular subject
for the photographic
lens as well.
So, for example -- I just want
to show you just a few examples
here, this is an albumen print,
which was taken outdoors
and it's a Hamal.
This is actually
another photograph,
it's a famous photograph that's
actually been used numerous
times in different
contexts across the decades,
and it is from the
studio of the Armenian,
the Ottoman Armenian
photographer Abdullah Phrese.
And it's also been used
as a as a postcard.
From the late 1890s, a lot of
these images were actually --
some of the more popular ones
were actually used as postcards.
And for example here you can
actually see four men arranged
pleasingly around a
barrel and two poles.
Of course, for every European
would actually receive this
postcard -- I mean, it doesn't
really say anything what a Hamal
is, but these are actually
the implements of their work.
Since the poles and the
barrel, which four basic --
four men, four men, six men or
eight men would actually carry.
So, there are two types of
Hamals, the Hamals who worked
as a group and Hamals who
basically carried the weights
on their backs as
single workers.
This is another interesting
photograph, and again,
I really don't have much time
to go into it, but LaShienda
who is -- it's really
encapsulate --
I don't have time to go into it,
but it really encapsulates
how a lot
of Constantinople Armenians --
but not just Constantinople
Armenians,
urban Ottomans really
look down at the Hamals.
And the street dogs were
also really, really common
in the streets of
Constantinople.
And so, you get lots of
images where the Hamals
and the dogs are basically
posing next to one another.
It really does -- it's a picture
that speaks a million words,
really, but anyway, we
don't really have much time
for photographer because we've
got paintings to look at.
The bantoukhd in Constantinople
became the major preoccupation
of the realists throughout
much of the 1880s
and the early 1890s,
with hundreds
of articles chronicling
every aspect of their lives
and experience in the city.
Yet no writer has looked
as closely as the bantoukhd
and represented his
experience to the extent
and with the sensitivity,
empathy and active employment
and involvement, as the educator
and noted chronicler
Melkon Grunyan, 1859-1915.
Writing under the
pseudonym "Herrant",
he represented the bantoukhd's
life in all its facets.
In his letters of the bantoukhd,
"bantoukhdin amakhner",
a series of 20 or so chronicles,
written in Constantinople
and published in by the then
weekly newspaper "Masses"
between 1888 and
1891 and "Highrenick"
between 1891 and 1892.
The letters, which according
to the literary historian
James Atmeckjean had given
unparalleled authenticity to the
literary realism of the time,
were usually addressed
through Arpyarian,
then editor of "Masses", at
whose request they were written,
and by extension
to a Constantinople
Armenian readership.
Employing language
that is simple, direct,
yet intensely visual, etfrastic,
Herrnat closely described
the individual bantoukhd,
painted being a man and probed
into the darkest little corners
of his soul, revealing
his innermost thoughts
and sufferings.
Himself a bantoukhd, unlike
most of the other realists,
Herrant knew his
subject intimately.
He castigated the contempt
with which urban Armenians
of Constantinople
denigrated and dismissed him,
relentlessly advocating the
provincial bantoukhds dignity.
Expressed concerned with a
luring of young men and boys
into what he termed
"ignoble professions",
such as male prostitution,
practice within homo-social
spaces such as the hammam
and other, has he termed
them, "abbatoirs of morals"
such as mayhanesse
and coffee houses.
Reproduced letters that he
himself had scribed on behalf
of illiterate bantoukhds.
In one such letter addressed
to a mother informing her
of the death of her son, we
are provided with a glimpse
of what he termed "a
black letter", seftaukhed,
thousands of which crisscross
19th century Anatolia,
carrying news of
death and sickness.
Like Herrant, Constantinople
artists too often took a close
and pathetic look
at the bantoukhd.
The bantoukhd Hamal from Mush --
its undated, but it was probably
painted in the late 1890s,
also by Simon Hagopian who
painted the earlier Hamals
on the bridge, is an
intense study of a migrant
where character
and psychological depth
have taken center stage.
Hagopian has skillfully captured
the likeness of an attractive,
dignified man on the
cusp of middle age,
where the empathy the artist
must have felt towards the
sitter is clearly reflected.
Here, the Hamal's direct
gaze breaches the gulf
between the subject,
artist and us, the viewers.
The neutral white background
avoids any distraction
from the subject, with
a Hamal claiming our
undivided attention.
Meanwhile, Arpyarian rights
of another earlier portrait
of a bantoukhd Hamal from Mush,
the painting "Manugahbarj",
"brother", "Manugahbarj" means
"brother", the whereabouts
of which are currently unknown,
by the highly respected 19th
century Constantinople artist
Petros Srabian, 1833-1898.
Writing in the popular
daily Arabic orient,
on the 25th of February
1884 under the pseudonym
"Herraskhan", he recorded his
and his friends responses
to the work.
"With a few friends we
visited Petros Srabian's home.
He had just completed
"Manuhagpbarj".
That slight face and
its feelings of sadness,
this faded eyes, skinny
fingers, the rags.
And I don't know what noble wind
was waving on his entire face,
turned us all towards
melancholy.
'What an odd thing' said one of
our friends, 'were I to see him,
the old man on the street, I
would certainly have passed him
by without the slightest
care, whereas by looking
at that painting, his eyes,
as if magnets pull my
glance towards them'.
The talented painter, by pulling
the old man's grief eroded" --
he used the word "veshtamash",
"hard softest strings,
had captured within his eyes
the most psychological".
He uses the word "hokipanagan",
which translates directly
as "psychology",
"psychological".
So, it's the most
psychological moment
and all the emotional
storms tormenting his heart
for 70 years.
Whilst Srabian's intentions are
not made explicit in the text,
we don't really know what he
actually sort of meant to convey
by sort of painting
Manugahbarj, and we don't know
where the painting is.
Despite the artist's
presence during the viewing
of the work so, when Arpyarian
and his friends view the work,
they were at the
artists atelier.
So, there must have been privy
to the artist's own
thoughts on the image.
The reviewers words clearly
suggests an allegorical reading,
which he notes, turned
him towards melancholy.
Another reviewer records
a similar response
to an earlier painting
by Srabian entitled
"Armenian beggar from Van".
And this is the image.
Now, this is a much
admired work --
and this is confirmed by
its election for exhibition
at the prestigious 1882
exhibition of the artists
of the Bosporus and
Constantinople, the ABC club,
under the patronage
of the British ambassador
Lord Dufferin,
and the favorable reviews
of contemporary viewers.
Fortunately for us, "Armenian
beggar from Van" is also one
of the very few works by leading
19th century Constantinople
artist, that is held by
a public institution,
the National Gallery
of Armenia in Yerevan,
where it is currently listed
as poor Armenian villager,
"ahcat haithuratzi" and, hence,
readily accessible
to art historians.
Consider the following
review of the work
by the prominent
Constantinople educator,
author and later
politician Minas Ceras,
in an article published
on the 28th of May,
1882 in the influential
Constantinople Armenian language
newspaper "Masses".
Under the headline, painting
exhibition "Negara huntys".
Writing under the pseudonym
"Ascazerj", which means "lover
of nation", he noted
-- and this is --
this is basically the paragraph
where the translation's from.
"The painting represents an
Armenian beggar from Van.
With his colorful rugs
and dark blue headdress,
who leaning towards
his stick looks
at the viewer with
pitiful eyes".
"The expression of this
painting is extremely tender
and heart-rending,
"hus desaruch".
The sensitive brush of
the author has succeeded
in personifying the
emigration bantkhdouitioun,
and plundering, [inaudible].
He actually uses
these words in print,
which is quite extraordinary
of our provincial brethren.
"I sought foreigners who was
saddened before the site".
He uses the word "yerevuit",
which translates to "site".
"And perhaps wasn't it
natural that I should weep?
I, who is not a connoisseur
of the Arts" --
he uses the word arvestahket",
"but simply any" --
and signs off "Ascazerj".
Ceras' reaction betrays even
more explicitly the attribution
of an allegorical interpretation
of -- to the image.
"Rather than being a benign
depiction of a beggar,
the image appears to have
conveyed certain troubling
messages to contemporary
viewers".
The concern trouble born artist
and art historian Raphael
Shmanian, 1885 and 1959,
notes that in the
1870s desperate battles
from Ottoman Armenia dressed in
rags and in wretched conditions,
nable to find work in the
city, would wander the streets
of Armenian populated districts
begging, often attacked abused
or chased away by
stone throwers.
Shmanian, just as Ceras in
the opening accept, drew --
in the above accepts,
drew a direct link
between the phenomena of begging
in at Constantinople
and bantkhdoutioun.
Yet Srabian's reference
to Van clearly signifies the
1881 famine, looming large
on the artist's and
reviewer's consciousness.
To Ceras, the painting
represented the personification
of plunder and destitution,
which he incredibly,
explicitly noted in print.
But also crucially in 1882,
famine, a subtle allegory
and the inability of Ottoman
Armenia to feed itself,
meanwhile the censors of
the committee for inspection
and controls, the authority
responsible for the approval
of all publications that
also included the scrutiny
of pictures, would have viewed
Srabian's beggar as a critique,
would not have viewed
Srabian's beggar as a critique
of the Ottoman state, but
instead regarded the painting
as a harmless, ethnographic
representation,
thus permitting its
uncensored exhibition.
What is certain is
that Srabian's beggar had
successfully bypassed any
sensorial constraints
and under a cloak
of seemingly benign ethnographic
naturalism, had conjured
within the brush what the pen
might not have been allowed
to express.
Just like the figure
of the machete hamal,
the beggar from Van appears
as a recurring theme among
Constantinople artists,
allowing them to engage through
such personification with
and comment upon the
words of Ottoman Armenia.
Let's consider two surviving
versions of Hagopian's beggar,
also by -- again,
Simone Hagopian's
beggar, a woman from Van.
The two versions of this 18 --
the first one, this one was
actually painted in 1889,
the second one's
actually dated in 1908,
and it's another version of
this, which basically means
that the artist kept
on producing
and reproducing the same image.
As in Srabian's beggar, nothing
detracts from the degeneration
and poverty of the old woman.
Hagopian's background
especially recalls the practice
of late 19th century
photographic studios,
of subjects being photographed
outdoors with a blank canvas
of the wall with its cracks
serving to reinforce an aura
of hopelessness, heightening
the realism of the scene.
Her bare feet and outstretched
hand, her fingernails inked
with black dirt evoke
the imploring fatalism
of the posture and pathetic
gaze of Srabian's male beggar.
The beggar woman's gender and
old age add further layers,
her destitution,
loneliness, defenselessness
and cruel abandonment in
a patriarchal society.
Hagopian has utilized
the gritty naturalism
and powerful realist
visual vocabulary
to elicit the empathetic
response of the viewer,
towards the poor and
dispossessed rural population
of Ottoman Armenia two years,
after another famine in 1887,
and the bundles on the streets
of the imperial capital.
Yet through this representation
of a provincial woman,
Hagopian may have also been
seeking to draw attention to one
of the most devastating
consequences of bantkhdouitioun.
The wholesale desertion
of thousands of wives,
or their abandonment altogether,
a major preoccupation
of the Constantinople
patriarch age and depress
in the late 19th century.
Many bantoukhds married
young, often at 12 or 14,
leaving their child
brides behind
to seek work in Constantinople.
Many of these men never
returned, abandoning their wives
to a life of mistreatment
defined by rigid tradition.
Following years of
brutality, slavery and abuse
by their absent husbands'
families and blamed
for the non-return of
the bantoukhd sons,
these women were often
put out on the street
with no options and no hope.
Newspapers are replete
with reports of women
who have been rejected
by their families,
had been left homeless, forced
to beg in their villages
or nearest and onerous towns,
and some indeed turn
to prostitution.
And others -- because the
Armenian Church would not allow
divorce, even though the husband
would have been gone for 20
or 30 years, they would convert
to Catholicism or Protestantism
to say they were
actually able to remarry.
Whether these works --
whether Hagopian's painting
of the beggar woman from Van was
ever exhibited, was displayed
in public or reviewed, I have
not been able to establish,
I have not find any,
any references to it,
with the exception that
the beggar woman from Van,
alongside the Hamals
on the bridge --
the first image that we
actually had look at,
were listed in a
short, biographical note
on Simon Hagopian's biographical
note of suit of by --
Simon Hagopian published
in Theotic's 1912 Almanac.
that attests that these were
among the artist's finest
and most renowned works.
And this is also sort of shown
by the fact that the artist kept
on reproducing the same work.
People would probably go
to him and ask for him
to actually repaint
the paintings so,
he produced several examples.
Now, there's one final work that
I'd like to sort of show you,
and it's a painting by another
celebrated Ottoman Armenian.
He's unfortunately
completely forgotten,
but he was a major
figure in Constantinople
in the 1880s and 1990s.
He was a society
portrait painter.
He was the Constantinople born
and Naples educated artist
Garabed Nichanian, 1861-1950.
Now, this painting of which
there are two versions,
and this is probably
the original version
that was painted in 1897
in Tiflis, and is, again,
luckily for us at the National
Gallery of Armenia in Yerevan.
The second one is a
smaller copy of it and it's
in a private collection
in Istanbul.
It's completely different
from the other --
of from the other images because
it actually depicts these people
in Ottoman Armenia.
So, this is a second work
by Garabed Nichanian,
who despite never having
been to Ottoman army aid,
I don't think he actually
ever left Constantinople
to go anywhere east,
outside Constantinople.
He also produced this
this famous painting,
which is now unfortunately lost.
It's in somewhere in the United
States and I've been looking
for it for the past three years
so, if anyone knows where it is,
it's in a private collection.
I had to show it just to
ask you if anyone knows
where it is, to let me know.
But luckily a photograph
exists of this.
And he has created this sort
of quite theatrical painting
of an Armenian wedding of Mush,
and again, he used bantoukhd
from the streets
of Constantinople
who basically confirmed his idea
of types of Ottoman Armenians
from Mush, who he
basically took to his Atelier
and he actually sketched them,
and he produced this
massive painting.
It's about two meters wide
and one half meters tall.
So, by Ottoman standards,
it's a pretty massive work.
But talking about this work,
I know that I'm out of time
and this was exhibited
in in Tiflis of the 1897,
Fifth Caucasian Art
Exhibit and it got really,
really extraordinary reviews.
And again, I won't go into it
but if anyone has any questions,
you can come and
ask me afterwards.
But I'd like to sort of point
out that it is a letter that is
at the center of
over the painting.
And the question is, is this
one of those black letters
that Herrant wrote
so much about?
Sort of, you know, taking
bad news from the Bantle son,
or perhaps the army in
hospital in Constantinople
or the patriarch
aid informing them
that their son has
actually died.
And the final point I
will actually make is
that this painting was
actually made in --
was actually executed in 1897.
Nichanian, alongside Srabian
and several other artists,
and lots of other Armenian
intellectuals actually left,
they were exiled
from Constantinople.
They escaped the 1894-1897
massacres, and some went
to Europe, some went to
Russian Transcaucasia.
And Nichanian ended up
in Russian Transcaucasia.
So, the point I'm
actually making is
that despite having
left Ottoman Armenia,
this artist was still
engaging with a phenomenon
of bantkhdouioun and
how important it was
for Armenian realists.
Thank you so much.
I'm sorry I'd run
over my time but --
[ Applause ]
>> The beauty of
having a conference
like this is you hear
so many new topics.
The downside -- the downside
is you don't have the time
to really delve into -- in
any depth, and all of them
so far have been magnificent.
And which leads us to the last
talk of the morning session,
and by friend and
researcher at the Library
of Congress while
working on his doctorate,
and noted lecturer
Hashit Muradian,
who is now at Columbia
university,
and he will be speaking
on "Unarmed and dangerous,
nonviolent resistance
from the Ottoman empire
to the Third Reich".
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, LaVon for
this phenomenal conference.
I feel like after talking
about arts and wealth,
talking about poverty
and art, you know,
it's an Armenian conference so,
there has to be the
great equalizer,
death and destruction
[laughter].
So, I'm here to deliver
that talk.
But I will do, however,
is along the lines
of LaVon's introduction where
he talked about how, you know --
when we think about Armenian
history, it's not just
about Armenians converting to
Christianity, the destruction
of the Armenian Genocide
-- some of these, like,
topics that we often really --
occupies our historiography
and public discourse.
But also even within
these histories,
there are important
aspects that are neglected.
Again, often for
reasons that have to do
with often political
circumstances,
other times because they are --
because of the unavailability
of archives, etcetera.
And the topic that I'm going
to be dealing with here,
in a comparative perspective,
is going to be the notion
of unarmed resistance.
This essentially constitutes
the focal point of my work,
because when we think about
mass violence in general,
what are we talking about?
The Army and genocide, the
Holocaust or other cases
of mass violence, the narrative
is typically one of asymmetry.
Genocide itself is
a manifestation
of the extreme asymmetry
where you have a powerful
group attacking another group
with the intent to
annihilate it.
This asymmetry gives
the impression
that the narrative have to flow
from one direction to the other,
and there's very little
that can hold against it.
This is important so, this
is like watching an avalanche
from a distance, right?
What we see is the Avalanche
taking everything in its way.
This merciless, unstoppable,
you know,
attack on everything in its way.
But ultimately, if we look
closer, every little component,
every little pebble, every tree
in its way is pushing back.
And this is the point that I
would like to make in this talk.
And I'm going to be focusing
on this idea of pushing back.
And pushing back itself,
resisting, it's not conditional
on the presence of weapons.
We can't -- it's
difficult to argue
that you need this machine,
this metallic machine
that propels gunpowder
and little bits of metal,
you need that to be present
for human beings to resist.
Yet, if we look at
the historiography,
up until very recently -- and in
general both in Armenian history
and beyond, the focus,
the emphasis is very much
on if any -- if there is
any, is on armed resistance.
So, here's a quote from an
Armenian woman who lived
in Aleppo during World War
I, talking about her husband
and what he did as
Armenian deportees
in the thousands were arriving
in what is today Syria,
what was back then Ottoman
Syria, beginning in May 1915
as a deportation and massacres
of Armenians are going on.
So, she writes -- this is
after the death of her husband
from disease that he
contracted from deportees.
She writes in the letter,
"my dear Badveli --
Reverend, barely out of
bed from his sickness,
disregarding the personal
hardships and peril
to his own life,
relentlessly labored day
and night to save other lives.
Together we pressed ourselves to
the very limit of our endurance.
All our time, energy,
efforts, sleep, food, clothing
and other material possessions
we put on the line on behalf
of this wretched, miserable mass
of torn and battered humanity".
Now, this is humanitarian work,
and humanitarian work typically
does not necessarily come
as resistance.
We -- I will allude to
this a little bit later,
but it's important to
note here that the work
that these humanitarians
were doing in Aleppo,
as the thousands of deportees
were arriving in a city
and the region, actually
constituted resistance,
what I refer to as
"humanitarian resistance".
Because it was being done
eventually against the will
of the authorities and by
essentially breaking the law.
So, this is not humanitarianism
--
an act of human tourism that's
being done under circumstances
where you have the
support of the authorities
or at least the neutrality
of the authorities,
but actually activism,
humanitarianism that is done
against their will,
by risking one's life,
by risking one's
imprisonment, etcetera.
So, it's important to highlight
this, this idea that any action
that occurs as being
won at engaging in,
in order to save a certain group
or individual, and in order
to fight back against a
certain group does constitute a
resistance, whether or not
there's a weapon involved.
Now, as I said, this is this
is common in historiography.
This is a quote from a scholar
who has written extensively
on resilience and resistance.
"By the 1950s and beyond,
historians who had examined
of European Jewry concentrated
on the perpetrators
rather than the victims".
Also very true in
the Armenian case.
"This inattention should
not come as a surprise,
given that the enormity
of the German crimes
overshadowed their victims.
Perhaps, too, it should
not come as a surprise
that early historians of the
period were primarily interested
in learning about the
forces that caused
such unprecedented destruction".
These are two examples,
one is that of the Warsaw Ghetto
Uprising which is, you know,
when we talk about
Jewish resistance.
You know, that is one typical
example that comes to mind,
and the other is the example
of the Armenians fighting back
on Musa Dagh, which has been
immortalized by Franz Werfel
in the novel "The 40
days of Musa Dagh".
Now, it's important to note that
in most cases of mass violence,
the majority of the targeted
population does not have access
to weapons, has no
training in weapons
or has no interest
in using them.
But this does not,
again, create a situation
where one is unable to resist.
"For decades, most scholars have
in fact shared the stereotype
of the resistance, presenting
it almost exclusively
as an armed action and
almost entirely masculine".
"Later, references began to
appear to unarmed actions
and those of women
but only rarely did
such mention go beyond an
emotional homage", again,
very typical of the
historiography
on mass violence in general.
Now, this is one of the
important problems here,
is that once we focus -- as
we think about resistance,
once we focus on armed
resistance, there are a lot
of things that are being
forgotten and neglected,
importantly women and the fact
that women also resisted in many
of these circumstances.
Most, however, did not
with weapons, right?
And I'll come back
to this later on.
Now, scholars have defined
resistance in a number of ways.
I will be showing
you a few definitions
from the Third Reich, World
War II and the Holocaust just
to give you an idea about
the way these definitions
are framed.
One definition, "a set of
the activities motivated
by the desire to thwart, limit,
undermine or end the exercise
of oppression over
the oppressed".
Notice how these more recent
definitions are a lot broader,
right?
There's no specific
reference to guns.
"Any activity designed to thwart
German plans, or perceived
by the occupiers as working
against their interest".
"Any group action consciously
taken in opposition to known
or surmise laws,
actions or intentions,
directed against the Jews by the
Germans and their supporters".
Now, the definition I use,
and I will be referring
to as I discuss the Armenian
case is the following,
"actions carried out illegally,
or against the authorities'
will,
to save Armenian deportees
from annihilation".
Again, there's no
reference to weapons,
it could be any kind of action.
And I will be giving examples
of a number of effective forms
of resistance that do
not employ weapons.
Again, it does not
make a big, you know,
Hollywood movie, right?
When you're not, you know, just
shooting and blowing up people,
but it's, again, it's important
to realize that what kind
of like, you know, the
small, the tiny sliver
of people have access
to weapons and the fact
that we cannot dismiss everybody
else, as people who just went
to their death like
sheep, right?
Which is something that is
commonly used both in --
by many in any reference to
genocide and mass violence.
Now, this is one example.
I started my talk by
referencing Reverend Ascijan,
who was assisting Armenian
deportees in Aleppo
as they started arriving
from all
over the Ottoman Empire
during the deportations
of the massacres.
This was -- he was just
one example of out of many.
The three Armenian
churches in Aleppo --
the Armenian community in Aleppo
was not deported at this point,
and only part of it would
eventually be deported later on.
So, all three Armenian churches
formed there, formed committees
to provide assistance and relief
to the Armenian deportees
arriving in Aleppo.
One of these committees
was headed
by father Haroutyun Yessayan.
This was a committee of the
Armenian prelisty of Aleppo,
and it included a
number of dignitaries
of the Aleppo Armenian
community.
Now, what did this committee do?
They mobilized tremendous
resources
and prepared detailed
reports about the deportees
who are arriving, in
order to best assist them.
Initially, there was no
government opposition
to what they were doing.
The Ottoman authorities --
and I argue this in my work,
we're dealing with other things,
and the local governor of Aleppo
who was very friendly
to Armenians
and he was actually
supporting these efforts.
Now, this committee met
every single day almost
and we have the minutes of these
meetings, which is essentially
like having a camera
in the city of Aleppo
as these deportees are
arriving the degree of detail
that you see here, these are
samples of a few of the minutes
of the meetings, is tremendous.
Now, what they did they
also prepared lists
of every single item that
was purchased in order
to assist these deportees
who are arriving in Syria.
We're talking about wood, we're
talking about food supplies,
bribes that were given
to Jandarmes and others.
Every single, you know,
Turkish lira, every single dime
that was spent is documented for
throughout the war in a couple
of ledgers of, as I
said, tremendous detail.
Not only that, but every single
receipt has been kept so,
you can imagine this offers
us a universe of information
and knowledge that really
allows us to look at this
from the perspective of
the victims, mind you in --
as the genocide is unfolding.
Now, it's important to note
that these efforts were
initially supported
by the local authorities.
Eventually this would
not be the case.
So, these actions,
these humanitarian
actions would soon morph --
change into humanitarian
resistance, as the central
and local authorities
start cracking
down on this humanitarian
effort, start arresting some
of its members and its leaders
and trying to stop these efforts
to assist Armenian deportees.
And notice, this is when I
argue this becomes resistance,
because at this point
you are doing it
against the will
of the authorities.
Now, it's important to note
that since this is an effort
that is unarmed resistance,
we see more
and more women involved,
in important ways.
This is one example
Nora Altoumyan was --
helped administer an
orphanage in Aleppo
and she played a key role in in
providing assistance and help
to many old friends whose
parents were killed during the
deportation massacres.
And now so, this is -- she's
in the picture here,
just see it center --
But there are many
other examples.
Another important fact
that I noticed in many
of these documents accounts, is
that the farther away you went,
one went from the
organized community,
the greater the role
of women became.
In many ways, as the Armenian
community itself was very
patriarchal in structure,
these committees were headed
by priests, and I mean
women could not --
I mean, just as a basic
statement here, right?
So, as you can imagine,
you know, again,
still although Armenian
were very active in Aleppo
and helping deportees.
But the farther away one
went in Syria into places
where the communities did not
have that kind of influence,
or into places that the
community did not have that kind
of access -- and I will
give an example of this,
the more you saw women
playing a more important
and prominent role in this
effort to resist, in this effort
to engage in actions against
the world of the authorities.
Now, humanitarian resistance
provided humanitarian assistance
to deportees was not the only
way in which Armenians resisted.
Another, a few other
important forms are have to do
with information, with
communicating and communication.
Communicating information
about what is going on,
both among the Armenian
deportees themselves,
and from the Armenian world
into the world at large,
in order to inform
newspapers, diplomats, consuls
and beyond the Ottoman Empire,
politicians and world leaders
about the plight of the
Armenian population.
And again, all of this
was done against the will
of the authorities and
secretly as one can imagine,
and often those who were caught,
arrested were imprisoned
or killed.
Now, I will give two
examples of this.
One is this image that you have
on the right, it is a photograph
of a handwritten newspaper in
one of the concentration camps
where Armenians were interned
during the Armenian side.
It is from Messghana
where, you know, you have,
at certain points, thousands
of the deportees crammed
in this area, where
daily dozens --
sometimes a few hundred people
are dying of starvation,
disease and deprivation.
And alongside food and
supplies and medicine,
a very important need for a lot
of these people is information.
They want to know
what is going on.
They cannot really -- they
don't have the option of going
out of these camps, these camps
are very well protected by --
again, are guarded by
Jandarmes and guards
in the inside, on the inside.
Their only way of acquiring
information is new convoys
that are arriving into the
camp a few times a week,
sometimes daily, new
convoys of deportees.
And there are these
individuals who would go
and ask these people what
they saw, who has survived,
what has happened in
the different parts
of the Ottoman Empire,
where they have been
and write them down.
And these little
pieces of paper --
and this is one surviving
sample of it, and then pass
that around among the
camp's population.
Now, the other example that
I would like to highlight has
to do with providing the
West, particularly Europeans
and Americans with
information about what is going
on in the Ottoman
empire as the destruction
of the Armenian population
is in progress.
In the city of Istanbul
itself, there were most
of the intellectuals as
we know were arrested,
beginning in April, 1915.
Some of those who were not
and managed to escape and went
into hiding actually formed
a committee that was tasked
with gathering the
information from the provinces
of what is going on, and
smuggling this information,
oftentimes on the sides
of printed newspapers
with invisible ink, etcetera,
into Europe for publication
in the newspapers there
and also for the diplomats
and politicians to
have access to.
This was a tremendous effort,
and a lot of these letters
and texts have been recorded
and have been published,
and it really indicates
the phenomenal work
that was being done in
terms of information
and communicating
what is going on,
as a form of resisting
oppression and destruction.
Now, an additional example of
resistance, unarmed resistance,
was the effort to save
as many Armenian writers
and intellectuals as possible,
particularly by two brothers,
the Mazloumian brothers who
owned the famous Hotel Baron
in the city of Aleppo.
Hotel Baron is one of the
landmarks, historic landmarks
of Aleppo it's a number
of prominent figures,
prominent historical
events have taken place,
prominent figures have
stayed there, and as I said,
a significant landmark.
And the two brothers who owned
the hotel actually use their
connections and access
in order to help,
save and assist Armenian
intellectuals
with the realization that
since this was an onslaught
on Armenian identity
and culture.
One of the important
ways to fight back
and keep the culture thriving is
through assisting the
who are upholding it.
Now, there are many ways,
as I approach some
general concluding remarks,
there are many ways
in which we can think
about individual agency.
It's important to note
that not every individual
who is subjected to this
onslaught, this, you know,
I used the image of an avalanche
earlier, will resist by taking
up arms, or will resist at all.
But most people will
exercise agency,
most people if not all people
will do something to survive.
And it's important
to highlight this.
Whether it's through
humanitarian resistance,
whether it's through medical
resistance, whether it's
through trying to
figure out ways
to survive one additional day,
individuals will
exercise agency.
And when we tell the
story of mass violence,
when we tell the story of
genocide it is important
to think about it
in the same manner.
If we ask the average
individual, average person
to describe what happened
during the Holocaust
in a few sentences,
the description will
probably go something like,
"this many Jews were
killed by the Nazis"
and make some references
to certain locations,
concentration camps,
death by bullets
and other important
salient aspects
that we know about
the Holocaust.
Very little will that
description have and hold
about the resistance
of the victims.
And in fact, almost -- there
will be almost no reference
to any unarmed resistance
by the victims.
Now, the very intention of
genocide perpetrators is
to erase the agency
of the victims.
It's the ultimate for of
you raising the agency
of the victims.
And inadvertently,
whether we are historians
or anybody discussing
whether we're dealing
in public discourse as
newspaper, as journalists,
and as writers and as editors,
when we describe crimes
and mass violence
in this manner,
when we are inadvertently
emphasizing the very thing
that the perpetrator
wanted to accomplish,
which is erasing the agency
and the voice of the victims.
It's important to
realize this asymmetry.
It's important, yes,
to understand
that the Nazis held tremendous
power, and no matter what kind
of resistance one engaged in,
it was very unlikely for it
to change things on a
tremendous, massive level as far
as the targeted population
was concerned.
Still, though, it's important
to think about these acts
of resilience --
resistance and resilience.
Not just in terms of success
rates, not just in terms
of how many people were killed,
how many Nazis were killed,
how many Jandarmes were killed,
but also to think about them
in terms of upholding
the dignity of the people
who are caught in this
avalanche, and in terms
of really telling their story
as part of the narrative.
And this I think
is an important --
this goes to the core of how
we think about mass violence,
violence and even violence
in our societies, emphasizing
and focusing on the perpetrator
and not really emphasizing
what the victim did often is
well intentioned.
It tries -- our attempt is to
show the victims as abject --
helpless, absolutely
helpless, and therefore as if
to make the crime look worse
and more horrendous
and more horrible.
But as I said, we are
-- what we are engaging
in is inadvertently
silencing the victims further.
This is very true in
the Armenian case,
as well as in a number of cases.
Again, the narrative of
absolutely helpless victims,
almost no agency and a state
that is using all the resources
at its disposal to
annihilate them is one
that compelling,
but it's not true.
It's not true, it's ahistoric
and it defeats the purpose.
The other aspect that's
important to notice that, again,
often because of in order
to make certain narratives more
appealing to a broader audience,
the emphasis on the
humanitarianism and the work
and the resistance of
groups and individuals
who are not members
of the victim group.
For example, in the Armenian
case we talk about the role
that the missionaries
played in helping
and assisting the deportees.
We talk about the role that
American diplomats played
in the years of deportations
and in the years that followed,
the huge amount of money that
were raised in this country
to assist the deportees, and
the survivors of the genocide.
Now, ultimately, though,
as these massacres were taking
place, no American diplomat,
no missionary was able to
access these deportees.
So, yes, tremendous amounts
of funds were raised,
but the individuals
were risking their lives
on the ground were more often
than not Armenians themselves.
More often than not
without weapons.
Again, it is important as we
highlight the important elements
of mass violence and the
importance of humanitarianism,
global humanitarianism -- and
again, a lot of this has plenty
of implications on
our day today.
It's important to realize
that we are at best
when we are supporting
and look --
any group, any community
in any part of the world.
At the best, no matter how much
assistance we're providing.
What we are doing
is to complement
and support the important
and significant role
that the locals are playing on
the ground against all odds.
So, I want to leave you
with a couple of thoughts.
Can one define the resistance
simply by one's access
to training in and
willingness to use guns?
Is resistance ineffective, even
impossible without a machine
that employs gunpowder to
propel pieces of metal?
The study of resistance during
the Armenian Genocide leaves
much to be desired.
The struggle against
genocide denial has produced
and perpetuated
perpetrator-centric narratives,
it was genocide, here's
why, and the related drive
for genocide recognition
around the globe has
produced Western humanitarian
centric narratives.
Your ancestors witnessed
it, saved Armenians,
now you should recognize it.
Thus, the action is genocide,
the reaction is Western outrage
and humanitarianism, while the
victims exercised no agency.
Treating genocide
largely as an action
of the perpetrator while
dismissing the reaction
of the victim is not
only ahistorical,
but inadvertently reinforces the
very attempt of the perpetrator
to strip the victims of
their voice and agency.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank You Patrick.
It's been an enlightening
morning session --
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.